awesome all at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking pronoia listen I'm a
tripod medic organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by freshbooks man oh man
do a lot of listeners on this podcast
and readers of mine love fresh books to
the extent that I ended up meeting with
the CEO not very long ago why are they
so popular well they are the number one
cloud accounting software designed
exclusively for self-employed
professionals that's many of you and
used by more than 10 million people you
can send invoices track your time and
get paid very very quickly which suits
the needs of a lot of freelancers a lot
of entrepreneurs and beyond you can take
pictures of receipts you can link your
credit card and debit cards so all the
things you buy automatically appear in
your fresh books in the right category
so on and so forth makes taxes easy
makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put the other PDF a
while back called breaking the time
barrier subtitle how to unlock your true
earning potential so you can search for
breaking the time barrier a lot of
people ask me how can I get a 4-hour
workweek with the service business and
the story in that ebook its PDF is the
short answer it's really really good so
I think you should also check that out
so breaking the time error check it out
but also why not test out fresh books
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial at fresh ebooks.com forward slash
tim and enter tim ferriss two hours in
two S's in me how did you hear about us
section that sounds like we're going to
get very little tracking that's a lot of
work but just go to fresh books comm
forward slash tim and try it out because
it is a very good product and i think
you will find it simplifies your life
enjoy
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I have used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time and it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neil Merritt's
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Rolf Potts Pio tts which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is always my
job to tease out the habits routines
philosophies favorite books etc from
world-class performers so you can test
each of those in your own life and
guests range from saying those in
business sports military all the way to
the esoteric and sometimes very
unexpected and this guest checks a lot
of boxes his name is Nick Szabo that's
SZ [ __ ] many of you may not recognize his
name but hopefully by the end you'll
want to know everything that he puts out
and read every essay that he puts on the
Internet he is a polymath the breadth
and depth of his interests and knowledge
are truly astounding and I mean
jaw-dropping it's it's just beyond
belief what this guy can cover he's a
computer scientist legal scholar and
cryptographer best known for his
pioneering research in digital contracts
and cryptocurrency and I have long been
fascinated by cryptocurrency but
secretly not really understood anything
about it or certainly the subtleties and
this episode is really a masterclass so
we go from the very very basic all the
way up to the cutting edge and what the
future holds Nick for instance developed
the phrasing concept of smart contracts
with the goal of bringing what he calls
the highly evolved practices of contract
long practice to the design of
electronic commerce protocols between
strangers on the Internet Nick also
designed bitgold which many consider the
precursor to Bitcoin this particular
conversation is co-hosted by one of my
favorite people navall Rafa Conte
a mutual friend and one of the most
successful investors in Silicon Valley
who also happens to be one of Nick's
biggest admirers and for those who enjoy
navall here you may also enjoy his first
episode with me from 2015 which was
voted on producthunt the second best
podcast episode of the year across all
podcasts with the exception of my Jamie
Foxx episode so you can listen to that
if you'd like it's called the
evolutionary angel episode
Timm vlog forward-slash navall but let's
get back to how much we cover with Nik
because it's a lot and you need not be
intimidated you don't need to be a
computer scientist I am NOT you don't
need to know anything about currency I
know very little but we get into the
history money we talk about Bitcoin what
it is what cryptocurrencies are and what
problems they solve we define social
scalability what is that and why is it
important what is a theorem what makes
it unique strengths and weaknesses we
talk about different types of
cryptocurrencies we talk about things
calling for instance altcoin what the
hell is that we get into it
what are I co s initial coin offerings
we talk about who might invest or not
invest and certainly this is not
investment advice it's for informational
purposes only so talk to your financial
professional before allocating resources
or money anywhere okay cover my ass good
how will smart contracts actually get
adopted to go mainstream right if you
think of say Bitcoin is something that
is very fringe when will it hit the
tipping point what might the elements be
that would lead to that blockchain
governance is there any existential risk
could governments or regulators shut
down something like Bitcoin what is wet
code versus dry code this is a super
super cool distinction that I really
enjoyed
what are Pascal's scams or quantum
thought we dig into all sorts of nooks
and crannies including what Nick might
work on in the future what fields does
he want to explore and so on so this was
to me a really really fun and
mind-expanding conversation you do not
need to be technical or an engineer to
enjoy it and get a lot out of it because
at the core we are really looking at how
to people who are very very smart
meaning Nick and navall process the
world what lenses they use to view the
world and how that dictates their
actions and how they get better results
so if you want more from Nick and we'll
talk about this at the very end of the
conversation also but you have to check
out the essays on his blog which is
called unenumerated unenumerated blog
spot.com but that can wait for later and
then you will know why many of the
thought leaders
[ __ ] Valley and around the world
really pay a lot of attention to Nick so
without further ado please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with Nick
Szabo all right
gentlemen I think the hour has arrived
Duvall welcome back thank you it's good
to be back once again Nick pleasure to
meet you right from you and I'm very
excited and also intimidated by the
conversation we're about to have its
context for people listening we're going
to delve into some subjects I have an
acute interest in what extreme ignorant
of leten have all do a lot of driving
and I figure the place we could start is
at the beginning at least where you guys
met so how did you two first connect
yeah I like most of my close
relationships these days I formed them
on Twitter and I think of Twitter as the
place where I go to to have a great
conversation when I can't have one
locally which seems to be all the time
and the more time that I spent on
Twitter the more I sort of curate this
incredible group of very intelligent
people that I just get to know purely to
the quality of their thoughts and so I
think when I was getting into
cryptocurrencies and blockchains
doing my homework on it I stumbled
across a blog called unenumerated and
maybe Nick can go into what the origins
of that word are but it was obviously
written by a polymath someone who wrote
about everything I got into the blog and
then I started following the author
which was Nick on Twitter retweeted
receive his tweets and got into little
bite-sized 160 character conversations
and here we are how is that relationship
developed in other words how are we here
today and you can take a stab at that
yeah Nick's gonna be plenty to talk and
certainly I have a hitman but if you
want to if you want to lead us to how we
ended up here today yeah I mean it was
just more and more tweeting back and
forth reading Nick's articles there's
one that he put up recently around
social scalability which I thought was
literally mind-blowing like I thought I
knew a lot about cryptocurrencies but it
really just helped me reframe what I
knew in a better mental model
in our Charlie Munger touch on mental
models so I've actually picked up at
least four or five mental models from
Nick which i think is more than I may
have from any human being other than
Charlie Munger I was tweeting out
sections of that article then somebody
said well Nick in the ball should do a
podcast and I was I didn't ever do a
podcast with me cementec said sure I'll
do a podcast so actually we are Nick
could you maybe help us with some
definitions so cryptocurrency there are
a number of other words they're going to
come up a lot and these are words that I
feel at many dinner parties and say
Silicon Valley people will not ask about
because they're afraid they're the only
ones at the table who don't actually
know how to define it since I I can't
play the part of knowing what I don't
know in this case what is cryptocurrency
and how did you become interested in it
or start thinking about it
cryptocurrency
as the name suggests is protected by
cryptography and in particular the
modern crypto currency like Bitcoin and
aetherium so forth are protected by
their integrity is protected by
cryptography a structure called a Merkel
tree that you can think of it as a fly
getting trapped in amber you if you say
I shot JFK and then put it through this
process of the Merkel tree putting it on
the blockchain then it's there you can't
and you've signed it with your with your
private key then you can't later deny oh
I shot didn't say that that allows you
to like make a statement you know I'm
paying such and such amount of Bitcoin
to somebody else and then put it there
after a few cycles called block x which
should take about ten minutes each
it gets exponentially more difficult to
deny or take back that that this
transaction took place how did you first
begin thinking about this these types of
constructs or any of this really where
did the interests of again well we had a
group called the cypherpunks back in the
1990's Tim May and air cues and John
Gilmore and so forth and Tim May had so
partly this is political that Tim May
had a a vision of Galt Scholten
cyberspace of any of your audience are
Iran fans little recognize the reference
to gulps goal to this place you can go
to get away from things and do your bid
without outside interference in the book
that was like a physics fantasy but Tim
goes well we have strong cryptography
now so we can do that and I thought well
yes but you still want to do things like
enforce contracts and protect property
and so forth so I started thinking about
and the some extent some other people
started thinking about how to apply
computer science to to protect your
business in cyberspace
this bleeds into I did just enough
reading to hopefully have questions to
ask and want to read so much that I left
out basics fundamentals for people
cryptography if most people think that
they're they hear that word maybe
exposure they've had is watching a movie
that involves an Enigma machine or
something like that but what is
cryptography the original cryptography
is if you saw that movie is keeping
secrets this case in that movie the
Nazis failing to keep secrets from the
British and Alan Turing because their
cryptography wasn't strong enough but
these days you have really strong
cryptography so breaking it in that
brute-force manner like they broke the
Nazi codes is pretty unlikely these days
there are some other things you can do
like take people's private keys and so
forth but the brute-force attack doesn't
work anymore I mean there are some old
ciphers where we're starting to work but
as long as you have the latest stuff
like Bitcoin does then you're fine yeah
I would say it's like basically keeping
secrets through mathematics and there
are many many breakthroughs that enable
crypto currencies but one of the key
things to understand in cryptography is
this concept of one-way encoding one-way
hash functions basically I can take some
data run it through a mathematical
transformation and what comes out of the
other side is really hard to undo it's
really hard to work backwards so it's
kind of a one-way thing so is when
people send encrypted email to say PGP
or something yeah is that an example of
that yeah basically what I've done so in
the old days if I was encrypting
something we would both have the same
key right and so or I would have a key
that I would take your key I would
encrypt with your key send it to you you
have the key and decrypt with the key
but the problem is how do I figure out
what your key is how do I know how to
cryptid and because your key can both
encrypt and decrypt so if I had a hold
of your key then I could open the
message right it was very unsafe to
transmit that key and so one of the
innovations that came along with this
idea of splitting the key into a public
key and a private key so private keys
what you hold on to that can decrypt and
encrypt stuff your public key on the
other hand other people can encrypt to
it for you but they can't use it I gotta
turn right only is that right only it's
a one-way kind of thing so I mean this
is probably beyond the scope of this
discussion but it's worth digging a
little bit into what are called one-way
hash functions and public keys and
private keys because they underlie a lot
of cryptography and they seem like
complicated concepts but they're not
that complicated and I would argue this
is one of those mental models that you
kind of have to figure out to start
operating the modern technological world
but crypto currencies essentially use
these one-way hash functions to make
statements like I gave Tim ten dollars
right so if I said I gave you ten
dollars normally we need a central
authority to verify that like the bank
has to verify that and the central bank
has to verify the Loosli answer the
question of and I'm not going to
interrupt beyond this but why why create
cryptocurrency why is it important what
are the benefits yeah so I mean one huge
benefit is we don't need anymore a
trusted third party to verify that
transaction we can do it in the cloud to
a distributed network which is kind of
what the cryptocurrency does but let me
talk more about this but he had a great
quote that I think is very relevant
where he said this is the dawn of
trustworthy computing right because
before this computers are kind of
untrusted like if I send you money from
my computer to your computer we're
really relying on Visa and the banks and
a bunch of intermediaries just actually
say yes the money got to you and the
money is no longer mine but computers
don't like to operate like that
computers you know computer code
especially stuff that's running in the
cloud on its own shouldn't have to rely
on an offline wet space meatspace
institution to enforce that kind of
thing so cryptocurrencies take the
concept of money and they take it
natives in to come
kut'rs where everything is settled with
computers and doesn't require external
institutions or trusted third parties to
validate things just to try to
paraphrase that for my own understanding
so in other words you don't have to say
trust a stranger to do something you
don't have to trust a central authority
to be the arbiter of whatever decisions
end up being made or implemented it's
built into the technology itself yeah
why why is cryptocurrencies important to
you so it's important for I think the
the partially political reason to gain
more independence of your life from
these institutions and it just creates
new capabilities like somebody now in
Guatemala convey somebody in Canada
without using an intermediary in New
York City or something that's greatly
advantageous for for a global commerce I
think yeah so if I can just dig into
that a little bit more definitely dig in
I also at some point because this word
has plagued me for a few years now
blockchain I do not know what it means I
don't know why it's called blockchain I
should mix a analogy of fly getting
trapped in amber it's kind of brilliant
like if you see a fly in amber and it's
got you know a millimeter of amber
around it well that could have been done
yesterday or you know a year ago but if
you see the fly is trapped in a huge
block of amber you know it's been there
for a long long time it's been
accumulating so a blockchain is a series
of blocks each block is a series of
computations done by computers all over
the world using serious cryptography in
a way that's very hard to undo so each
block is like another thin layer of
amber I say and the chain of blocks
represents the depth of that amber how
long that fly has been trapped in and
therefore how you can trust that on a
signal anything deep down in the
blockchain is mathematically
cryptographically and just economically
impossible to undo got it
okay I shouldn't use words like
impossible in cryptography as although
it was always probable Allium probable
yeah what are some other core concepts
that people should understand
just as the
cryptocurrency 101 or currency 101 I
mean depending on where we want to go
even want to start with like what is
money sure because we're throwing around
the word currency and money and people
talk about gold in store of value and
you know Nick actually created bit cold
which was some would argue a critical
foundational predecessor to Bitcoin
Bitcoin had an additional breakthrough
or two that it employed that pickle did
not but bit cold was the Giants on whose
shoulders bitcoin stands and Nick also
created both the the phrase and the
concept and the theory behind smart
contracts which we're now starting to
hear about in the context of other
cryptocurrencies like etherium but I
think we should just this is a
complication of topic that it's worth
just starting with like what is money if
you ask 10 people on the street what
money is you probably get 10 different
answers sure so I think it's important
just be rigorous about that and if you
ask a lawyer you'll get an answer that's
radically different than if you ask an
economist as well if you ask a lawyer
they'll say something like an official
government currency so of course bitcoin
and gold you can't write checks for
those because those are not legal
official government currencies so that's
the that's the kind of neuro modern
legal definition economists use the
definition of medium of exchange which
is a much broader definition but that
also assumes it you know the only
important transactions are people
exchanging things which in our modern
economy is a good assumption but if you
actually go back to the origins of money
which I've liked to study I'm you find
things like inheritance and compensation
for injuries as equivalent to a modern
lawsuit but not necessarily with
governments and courts more like Wars to
enforce the force of the verdict and
Bridewell there's certain fitness
critical critical to Darwinian fitness
that other animals can't do the humans
can and that form of I like to call it
collectibles because not have extended
the definition money far broader than
probably any economist would want to but
so I out calls collectible so it's very
similar so the Yurok Indians for example
use shells to and they would have tattoo
marks on their arm they were serious
about their shells it would have tattoo
marks in their arm to measure the
lengths of shells and that told you the
denomination the value of how valuable
that shell was which corresponds to how
scarce at what
in nature and they would use these for
inheritance for injury compensation for
bride wealth and so forth yes it sounds
like you know as so I think that the
common theory is that humans have only
been using money for a few thousand
years but I think some of the work
you've done on origins of money shows
that actually it's hundreds thousand
years yeah you can go back an
archaeological record and it's a puzzle
for a hundred thousand years in our
Darwinian world that people lived in why
people do something so frivolous as you
know adorn themselves with shell
necklaces yet those are among the most
common artifacts right up there with
axes practical axes that you use to cut
things in the archaeological record yeah
so I mean on the money thing like I've
also tried to wrap my head around this
and as Nick said economists would say
it's a medium of exchange as the
historical record shows it's a store of
value so even if you're not exchanging
it you just want to go store value you
may not want to store bread or rocks or
houses so you store the imagine a more
practical yeah a transport exactly and
then it's also a unit of account so in
other words like you have to denominator
Isis and something I'm not going to tell
you how many loaves of bread a car costs
so I need to be able to just take a unit
of account - don't judge I only have
that occasionally so it is all of those
things and I think one of the places
where people fall down on
cryptocurrencies that they say well no
one's using Bitcoin to buy anything
right now so it may not be fulfilling
the medium of exchange function but it
is it may be fulfilling a different
function external value it might be a
Swiss bank account in everyone's pocket
or in their mind or it might be the
defense against the Cyprus style bank
haircut or it could be the future that
is here but not evenly distributed and
probably it's and you can go to Palo
Alto the Copa café and bike on Bitcoin
right now yeah and and with it within my
social circle there is a large group of
people who will take Bitcoin as legal
tender like you can go to them and
settle debts in Bitcoin and they will
happily take it or if you want to buy
say a scientific abstracts or articles
from a Russian website they may only
take a coin as well yeah and I just seem
a little bubbly which is either you kind
of say well it's only money because
everyone believed this money but one
definition I really liked of money is
money the bubble that never
so if we had if the tulip bubble had
never popped we'd probably be dealing in
tulips today now it pops for fairly good
reasons which is tool to make for lousy
money they're hard to store they're hard
to transport they're hard to subdivide
but cryptocurrencies actually are the
exact opposite end of that scale they
are easier to store easier to transport
easier to subdivide cheaper in many ways
and more defensible than almost any
other form of money or gold or commodity
now what makes since we're talking about
money or currency what makes money
valuable I think this might be
interesting to just dig into for a
second because you have say at certain
points in time paper pegged the gold
right and then it's reading today
because it's another word that I've seen
a lot but aside from the car company I
was not sure what Fiat really meant so
if we're talking about don't even know
if there's even even around anymore what
distinguishes say cryptocurrency or
makes cryptocurrency valuable is it the
rarity what are the factors that that
determine that well I mean the scarcity
is an essential essential part of it you
if it starts inflating on you then
you're sure if it goes down so the
scarcity is quite essential to it other
things are you want it to be easy and
secure to store and transport and and
Bitcoin has the advantage it you can
send to people all over the world and
store it on a hardware wallet which is a
fairly secure way to store it and the
most important part of it what is a
hardware wallet so hardware wallets so
your normal computers are pretty
insecure and that's one of the stories
of blockchains is that this distributed
system is a lot more secure than an
individual computer so your own computer
could have malware viruses and so forth
so hardware well it's a separate piece
like on a USB stick you plug in has its
own chip on it and the Bitcoin your
private key gets stored on that chip
rather than on the computer so that yeah
there's a zillion ways to store Bitcoin
you could do it on your computer but
then your computer's connectivity to the
internet security hole you could put it
in an online exchange but then you're
just trusting an unregulated Bank you
can put it in a hardware wallet which
says make set a dedicated device
you can put it on a piece of paper and
stick it in your bank account and that
in cold storage Oracle's outage yeah
that's cold storage which is where I
know the words but not yet I mean this
is this is one of them yeah this is one
of the crazy things about this concept
because money in money and speech turned
out to be the same thing
money information math they're the same
thing so in a Bitcoin world I can
literally write down my Bitcoin address
and keys on a piece of paper and put in
a safety deposit box and it's basically
in cold storage I could even put it in
my head I can memorize the key phrases
and I could cross borders with a billion
dollars in my brain so in that it's a
very powerful but mind-bending literally
concept in that sense is this point
where makes sense to talk about smart
contracts or is that a non sequitur no I
think order is there good bridge yeah no
I think I think we should get into it
first I want to make sure that we
understand what block chains in Bitcoin
are right might be worth going into like
what are the key innovations that
enabled Bitcoin and I won't leave you to
dictate when is make sense or out of you
guys but the article you sent me about
the I guess fad protocol layer right
I'll get into that later
okay we'll get there that's a little
teaser for flash I'll let you lead at
them yeah so I think it's worth getting
into like what is the Bitcoin computer
right because there is basically you can
abstract and think of Bitcoin is running
on a blockchain computer and maybe Nick
can take a stab at defining what it is
by the way this is one of those things
where I think if you ask 10 different
people in cryptocurrencies what bitcoin
is and what a blockchain is and what
botching computer is you'll get 10
different answers you know some people
are more qualified than others well it's
also just it's new it's hard to figure
out these are very abstract concepts
ideas being turned into code and they
are all Bitcoin is almost two computers
what I want like quantum mechanics is
the physics it throws a lot of people in
the field off well it's also like
quantum physics because you have a lot
of well-intentioned like hippies and new
AG people who miss appropriate yeah and
use it completely incorrectly absolutely
so not to say there are a lot of needy
people getting into cryptocurrency there
might be but I think you also have that
yeah there's layers of understanding
like I don't know how to
code for a Merkel tree I don't know how
to take a part of Bitcoin block and
analyze it so in some level I'm still
you know a new-agey hippie trying to
figure it out
but I think it's worth getting into like
what is the blockchain computer and how
does it enable Bitcoin I guess first of
all drop into that another important
concept to the architecture that as I
mentioned yet is replication so there's
thousands of copies of these things
running on what are called full nodes
all over the world their servers right
right so they're their servers that can
be laptops or larger machines but there
are thousands I'm running all over the
world so anybody who has a copy of this
can their machine can do a full
validation for itself it's kind of the
most secure way to run run a
cryptocurrency yeah so sorry to
interrupt you but basically what's going
on is if I give Tim ten dollars and then
Tim gives Nick those ten dollars the way
we you track of it is to a piece of
paper or in the old days of the Yurok
indians it would be a shell of a certain
measurement but now at Bitcoin there's a
ledger we basically just keep track in a
ledger entry that navall moved this ten
dollars - Timm Timm moved ten dollars -
Nick now the problem is who maintains
the sanctity of that ledger
can you just Forge that ledger so
historically the central bank would
maintain the sanctity of the ledger or
the fact that you have a certain dollar
bill with a serial number it maintains
the sanctity of the ledger but now
bitcoin has the craziest answer you can
imagine but it turns out to work which
is everybody has a copy of the ledger so
every one of the Bitcoin network who's
running a node keeps a copy of the
ledgers from the dawn of Bitcoin tool
now and there is a testament to the
computing power and memory that we have
available in modern computer that people
can do this at home you can run a full
Bitcoin node where you keep a copy of
every single Bitcoin transaction from
the dawn of time till now and all these
computers running together essentially
validate with each other like are our
Ledger's the same are we using the same
ledger whose ledger is correct in case
it's a disagreement and that's where
kind of all the blockchain comes in
doing all this cryptography and then
another thing that's replicated
besides the data and the integrity
cryptography we talked about is code
computer programs
and kind of the second definition of
smart contracts we'll get into the first
definition later but the second
definition is simply describing this
code that's replicated that's running on
all these nodes and that code can do
things like enforce on Bitcoin and can
do some fairly simple things that add
some sophistication or like require
multiple signatures to do a spend for
example so like you can think of
signature Authority and offers for
multiple people have to sign off on
something you can set up your Bitcoin to
do that using one of these smart
contracts one of these pieces of code
replicated it might be taking us back or
taking us ahead or neither we were
wandering through the blockchain it's
complicated yes a smart contract in
essence are you taking what would rely
on human beings and embedding it into
the technology so that there's you don't
have to rely on a standard set of ethics
reliable set of behavior is that a smart
contract yeah so to some extent there
are some areas of contracts some kinds
of contractual clauses usually but not
always associated with the financial
aspects of the contract that you can
they're really logically structured and
you can code that into the computer put
it on the blockchain and then it runs
with a really high integrity and that
means that somebody in Albania can do a
smart contract with somebody in Zimbabwe
and to the extent that they can
formalize their deal mathematically with
through this logic code they don't have
to rely on Albanian authorities or the
Zimbabwe authorities they can just do
business directly and you had a great
term for this this is getting into the
drivers as wet code right so dry being
computer-based when I'm being
potentially the legalese in the head of
a lawyer in Albania and the legalese in
the head of lawyer in Zimbabwe which is
going to be a whole whole just slew of
mess potentially right so I like to
think all that illegally if you fee in a
contract of as a as a program that runs
on the brains of a lawyer doesn't
usually run on brains of normal people
that this is going to I'm trying to take
us too too far afield what we're talking
about how do you
interesting context so it's part of I
guess libertarian ideology but it's also
part I went to law school and it's also
part of Law School 101 that property and
contract law that kind of two
fundamental building blocks of our
commercial society yeah so I was
interested in how do you enforce those
in cyberspace I don't meet many people I
meet people who have say JD MBA or JD
PhD I don't meet many people who have JD
and computer science degree and
libertarian on top of I am libertarian
on top of that although I have heard
there some libertarians running around
the bay area yeah JD apparently I'm a
libertarian I've been told relatively to
the average person so I live in 71 owned
guns and they're like you're a
libertarian I'm like I didn't really
think that easily I got like Mike my
card okay how did you end up doing both
of those degrees I haven't run into that
before the law degree is in large part
based on smart contracts and wanting to
do a reality check of the stuff I
thought of as a computer science I see
so the computer science came first yeah
and then the JD was I went to study the
wet code then now that I know how a
computer works let me go look at an
advocate and see what that's like okay
very cool yeah so I think some of this
is smart contracts which by the way as I
said earlier Nick created not just a
concept of the theory behind it smart
contracts are essentially taking that
wet code converting into dry code and
then putting it inside blockchain so
it's immutable after a while that it's
it becomes a fly trapped in amber if we
made an agreement and the simplest smart
contract by the way it's just I gave you
money and you got the money that's a
very very simple contract that got
fulfilled so but you can put much more
complex so contract is promise and
fulfillment of promise or is there an
easier way to think about it because
when I think contract I think of all
these clauses are right termination
arbitration term etc I think of all
these because I look at which other
contracts now so you can think of the
primordial granddaddy of all smart
contracts is the vending machine so a
vending machine in
in contract law terms it verifies the
performance you put in your quarter and
it verifies you put in the quarter
through its mechanical I'm talking about
old-fashioned machine it has logic in
that says okay you put in a quarter the
soda cost a dime so I'm going to give
you a diamond and nickel back and the
soda you selected so you can think of
writing this in a contract tediously
that you know if if the party of the
first puts in a quarter you know the
party of the second will give them back
but of course you want to do this in
machine right you know so give the
lawyers any ideas it's verifying a
performance on the one hand somebody
it's observing that somebody did their
payment or their other performance of a
contractual deal and on their hands
automating performance its dispensing
dispensing the goods so the codes the
kind of the two basic things smart
contracts can do they verify somebody's
performance and they automate
performance now the third thing is if
you have and there's a bunch of stuff
that's inherently wet most of the stuff
that you can code into smart contracts
as those two kinds of things are like
payments and various financial
conditions you can do a lot of financial
stuff like options and collateralized
loans and so forth
futures but for things that are
inherently wet though nobody's figured
out how to have the computer verify
automated performance yet you can you
know invoke an arbitrator a signature
structured like multi-sig to have humans
approve certain steps in what will be an
example of where you or someone else
might want multi SIG's
in that universe if you're doing
something with an escrow for example
that you have the person or persons
responsible for the collateral verifying
that the contract was performed then
they can free up the collateral got it
so if you wanted to buy a house that had
to do inspections you want to use
Bitcoin right yeah it'd be a good
situation yeah and there are things you
can do now with smart contracts what you
call on chain where you can have all the
money and a collateral and the escrow
and the data as close to computerize as
possible so the stuff that people are
starting to do with smart contracts now
it's pretty mind-blowing can we
talk about the article you sent me and I
know it seems like it might not be the
right is very helpful to me
sure so do you want to dig it yeah so
there's this concept of what bitcoin and
aetherium and these other
cryptocurrencies are doing is they're
they're the new protocols and what is
the protocol a protocol is kind of like
a god I'm going to get trapped in
definitions but a protocol is sort of
how computers it's a standard for how
computers exchange information so for
example you and I speaking the English
language is a form of protocol but then
also like HTTP yeah I'm supposed to
pause every five seconds and then you're
supposed to get a chance to speak that's
part of the protocol we say hello to
each other's greeting it's part of the
protocol so we have verbal packets like
these yeah exactly and also another
protocol yeah and then the internet
these protocols are tcp/ip HTTP SMTP
every time your email gets sent from one
server to another it's using the SMTP
Simple Mail Transfer Protocol and these
protocols power the Internet and the
assumption that we've made in the early
days of the internet was that well Bend
with these cheap servers or cheap
hardware is cheap so it's free if I want
to send you a packet it's free if you
want to receive the packet it's free
doesn't cost anything but those
assumptions are breaking down
we've denial of service attacks which is
basically your computer demands
resources from my computer that I'm
saying no but you're asking so many
times for free that it just overwhelms
me spam is another example I can send
you a zillion email that hardly any cost
but it costs you a lot of attention so
these free protocols are becoming poor
assumptions the worst place for a poor
assumption on a protocol is a protocol
for exchanging money if I say Tim I want
to give you ten dollars that has to be
scarce in some way it can't just be it
can't be a free transaction right
because it's money this exchanging hands
so we need a concept of protocols that
underlies scarce resources but allocate
scarce resources and what's going on is
crypto currencies and block chains are
creating these what are now being called
fact protocols and we'll put an article
in the in the show notes about this but
fad protocols are protocols that
actually exchange scarce value and to
keep data in the protocol they maintain
data that's the key
pease right or in a way yeah there's two
key pieces one is scarcity which is
regulated by a token so in the Bitcoin
protocol the scarce piece is the Bitcoin
itself and the protocol is about the
exchange of money and the token is
Bitcoin and then there's data that you
can put in the blockchain like I could
for example take a article that I wrote
I could hash it the one-way crypto hash
put it in the blockchain prove that it
came from me and then it gets trapped in
the amber again like the fly and no one
can undo it later and it's secured by
the value of the blockchain so these new
protocols these fad protocols are very
different they're going to exchange
they're going to enable a new kind of
internet that we did not have before
that's a thesis of kind of the fad
protocol argument just for people
listening who like me we're trying to
find their way their way through the
darkness with a lot of stuff when I read
that piece which is on the Union Square
Ventures website yeah hi Fred and guys
I'm blanking on the name of the author's
very good you'll want tonight there we
go and the before and after example that
was given or one of them was you have
these thin protocols HTTP etc and then
you have these services built on top of
them that becomes silos of information
whether that's Facebook Google whatever
it might be and then they develop their
own means of authentication and so on so
you have these captive stores of
information you have security risks on
top of that so now perhaps you're doing
your banking through a web server and
conversely when you then have VI 80s or
the democratized data that is built into
the protocol itself say in the case of
Bitcoin where now you have all these
nodes that have for the purposes of
illustration every transaction start to
finish it's more secure you're less
captive and it conforms to the
libertarian /im Rand ideal that we were
talking about earlier and the
illustration that was given that I
thought was fascinating and may or may
not hold true for for decades but was
that you have protocols they're
necessary
but not valuable right there they're
available there like utility to the
public and then you have these these
billion-dollar multi-billion dollar
companies built on top of the Facebook
Google etc then you have conversely
Bitcoin which has a market cap of X I
don't know district 5 billion - okay and
then the companies built on top of it
are internationally small by mid tens or
hundreds of millions at most right so
it's a complete flip in terms of yeah
the value of getting captured by the fat
protocol yeah I do recommend this
article it's actually John Joel money
grow like that is lessening wrong but
you wrote a brilliant piece on this but
the thesis is that because these
protocols are storing your identity and
data on the on protocol in the protocol
itself the applications don't capture
you as much you're not stuck in the
applications and the value is captured
by the tokens in the protocol does that
mean this is this is just putting on the
investor hat for a second that people
are going to be incentivized to just
create more and more different types of
cryptocurrency and then reserve to try
to capture that that's exactly what's
happening so I wrote a post on is called
the Bitcoin model for crowdfunding and
this is a couple of years back and I
thought these things called app coins
would show up but for every application
rather than going and raising VC money
you just attach token to it you crowd
fund it and that's kind of what's
happening now with what they call AI
CEOs initial coin offerings and there's
been hundreds and hundreds of these and
you know it's a little bubbly in fact
it's very bubbly a lot of them are
getting bit up out of control some of it
comes from the fact that a few of these
protocols do need their own token they
can't use Bitcoin but most of the times
it's really just the developers have an
incentive to create a token bolted on
and try and capture the value but it's a
it's an interesting model for funding
open source software and protocols that
didn't really exist before our bubble is
a bad thing and this is this is
something I've also been reading about
that I'm really out of if you have any
any thoughts on this but in many
people's minds bubbles are a bad thing
but I read a counter-argument for the
first time today which was you know
after a bubble bursts then you have out
of the money investors who are
incentivized in Greek in regaining the
value of what is declined by creating
services
and applications that are now these sort
of seen applications which then
preserves the sort of long term
viability of X whatever that might be
which I hadn't really considered before
well there is a fence in which many
bubbles are unavoidable because the
future is a genuinely uncertain place
yeah especially this is these are
reflexive industries where you know the
notion of reflectivity is like my
prediction alone changes the potential
outcome and you know the extreme example
is like a prediction market predicting
the death of somebody if there's enough
money on that it turns into an
assassination market so bubbles are
inherently I think just a part of any
system that involves Network effects if
I think then and money is the ultimate
Network effect I accept US dollars as
money because you accept US dollars as
money and so on if we all believe that
if you all believe tomorrow the tools
were valuable again we'd be trading in
tulips right so if I believe that you're
going to accept this as money then I
want to put more money in and you want
to put more money in the network effect
sort of creates a bubble and as Nick
said the futures in an uncertain place
so sometimes we'll be wrong about to
step back there'll be a little bit of a
releasing of energy I read something a
couple of years back that's that showed
that as the stock market is becoming
more efficient it's actually becoming
more volatile it's not becoming less
volatile more volatile because it's
reacting faster and faster to
information changes that's like the
story I want and you can look at
long-term capital management or there
are all sorts of high-frequency trading
you see you have not only humans right
who are increasingly interconnected but
you also have computers right now
there's a big train development in China
that causes a political change that
causes the futures market in China the
shift that causes the US stock market to
go down right computers are getting
better and better at absorbing that
information extrapolating out the
consequences and and so the markets have
become more and more volatile so over
time we should see bubbles form faster
pop more quickly and I think they'll
fall into a power-law distribution like
there there'll be ones that will be
really large they'll be one that'll be
really small and but this idea that the
future is going to be very smooth
lair and predictable is a human illusion
yeah no I think that's fair assumption
Nick what are the biggest misconceptions
or common misunderstandings related to
cryptocurrency or Bitcoin or
or like what is smart people get wrong
if there's anything we're going to
god.this like x drives me nuts if I hear
one more person you should know better
haha well we could get into the whole
block size issue because there's this
parameter we shouldn't but I probably
will talk about a little bit there's
this there's a it's a technical security
parameter it's called the block size how
the general public glommed onto this I
do not know but there's there's an
obsessive group of people who think of
this as some kind of artificial barrier
to more transactions per second on
Bitcoin really it's its job as its its
offense preventing people from
overwhelming flooding the network with
lots of transactions at the full nodes I
talked about can't handle that that
transaction history keeps building and
building you had a very simple level if
if every computer is throwing a copy of
every transaction then you can't have an
infinite number of transactions because
when Peter will explode and so what you
do is if you if you keep increasing the
number of transactions to two quickly
then you only allow a smaller and
smaller shrinking set of computers to
run the code which reduces who who's
actually in charge of security before
you might have had a million computers
then you're down to one hundred thousand
big computers then there's only a few
thousand large players then eventually
down to five people who can store the
entire history then you're basically
back to central bank's alright so the
debate is should we keep allowing more
and more transactions because what if
people everyone wants to buy a Starbucks
using their Bitcoin or should be only
limited to very high value transactions
and instead preserve the diversity of
people who can who can run the code yeah
I mean this shouldn't even be a public
of it's like the public debating and
voting on the graphite reactor setting
or graphite thing settings that prevent
a nuclear reactor from
heating and melting there let them
debate the bike shed yeah and there are
certain things you should let the
engineers decide and this is one of them
and for some reason there's just a whole
group of people who want to want to pull
out those graphite moderator rods and
have it going full-steam yeah one of the
problems with the bitcoin is that
because a lot of people hold a little
bit of Bitcoin everyone has a financial
incentive and they're all talking their
own book and they get really emotional
about it
Nick had this great tweet that I like
the best way to destroy your investment
in Bitcoin is to gather an Internet mob
to go and redesign Bitcoin right and
there's a little bit of what's happening
right now well you were saying before we
started recording that a lot of you
you've never seen so many scientists be
uncivil towards one another yeah I think
I think the worst twitter is Trump
Twitter where everyone's getting
outraged over politics all the time but
the second worst Twitter right now is
blockchain Twitter where you will have
PhDs from Cornell and University of
Maryland all kinds of credential places
literally calling each other horrific
names online casting aspersions other
people's moral cat moral character
calling them trolls dragging them
through the mud and they they each have
their little local tribal mob behind
them over things like the block size
debate which has Nick says you know it's
like chaining the parameter settings in
a nuclear reactor well it's I mean it
makes me think of having a bunch of sort
of expressions that jump to mind you're
saying you've talking their own book so
the onion form has to be very careful
about asking a barber if they need a
haircut right you need to know what the
incentives are as I'm sure people have
heard the expression it's not very
flattering but man is as loyal as his
options it might be a scientist
Kirk someone who is otherwise civil is
as civil as their incentives right yes
once you have enough to gain or lose
yeah incentives are everything like
Charlie Munger says if you can be
working on the sentence don't work on
anything else and in fact you know going
back to Bitcoin the Bitcoin design for a
second Bitcoin is brilliantly designed
because the underlying game theory
incentives yeah could we talk just for a
second about what is bitcoins we talked
about cryptocurrency
what makes but what made but kind of
what makes Bitcoin unique if that's if
we could maybe talk about that you can
think
in a couple errors the the most
important and fundamental layers of
computer science later layer where we
proved that it would take 51 percent of
the computational power of the hash rate
to attack this thing and do things like
double spend if you're changing that
ledger right yeah you can't change the
ledger the beauty is the fly and amber
analogy is a great one because once we
you and I have done a transaction the
network has agreed on the transaction
going back and then doing it is nearly
impossible but while that amber is being
laid down we can still be some mischief
so one of the big misconceptions of
Bitcoin is that well if 51 percent of
the computers in the network them which
are run by people called miners the coal
miners it's the old announcer digging
for gold so they're digging for a
Bitcoin but really what they're doing is
they're laying down that Amber it's 51
percent of these people collude then
does that mean they can go back and
change the ledger no they can't change
the existing ledger but they can cause
mischief with the current transaction
under the current layer that's being
laid down it's one of the big
misconceptions so sorry to interrupt
yeah so that's one of the computer
science limitations of it and the other
one is doing software upgrades software
upgrades kind of change the rules even
more so yeah and so those two things end
up getting especially the software
upgrades end up getting very politicized
yeah Bitcoin fundamentally what what's
going on it's a NIC first create a bit
gold right you want to talk about what
the innovation in bit gold was or how
the big goal system worth making later
on Bitcoin I'm sure I mean big gold was
inspired by the kind of origins of money
research and how do I and also there was
an era called private banking or you
could take your your bank note and go up
to bank one knowing it gold and the bank
the paper money we have today looks very
much like these bank notes did I'm a
thing I call authority resemblance or
sort of faking and pretending too that
this is still really valuable stuff and
the illusion works apparently for most
part but but they used to work very
differently used to be able to go up to
window and get actual gold for your
paper
yeah and that's not ellipses if you mean
to green flattened tulips you know if
debt now it's just the paper itself you
got to just trust the paper itself in
the Federal Reserve but in any case I
was inspired by what peaches of fiat
currency I right right right
fiat currency is just a paper that's
backed by nothing so before it was
shells then we went to gold then we went
to gold back paper and now we're down to
just paper okay
creating that banknote itself is easy
enough to do that's basically what
PayPal and company has working for
called digital cash with David Chen and
stuff for doing that trust based paper
note that was issued by some central
authority but I became too satisfied
that because in the end of day you want
to go to that window and get something
else that's more what I call trust
minimized so gold is valuable all over
the world if you go back to these more
primitive tribes the gold and the
shelves and so forth you know you can
pay them to the next tribe next crime
over all your neighbors would accept
them as well they wouldn't accept your
your IOU because you know you're going
to trust people you could go war with
tomorrow but they would accept the
shells or the copper beads of the gold
beads the first gold artifact by the
ways of being the first copper artifact
so apparently the most important
earliest uses of metal not knives or
weapons or tools or so forth any case oh
so I was looking for this trust
minimizing like how to do this in
cyberspace since I had red stuff I know
it's not just a magical property of gold
that makes it valuable and other things
aren't or something or some intrinsic
you know it started off you can use it
in let you know electrical circuits or
so forth no there's something about what
I call the unforgeable costliness of at
the scarcity of it the naturally trust
minimized scarcity of it you don't have
to trust somebody to keep it scarce I
try to recreate this in cyberspace using
proof-of-work atom backs hashcash and so
basically the bit cool design did that
and then it used a replication technique
which it originally developed that I
apologize backtrack but the proof of
work would eat what you mean than that
okay so proof of work is a mathematical
puzzle a computation that the computer
does that says okay you have to solve
this and we know from computer science
it'll take so long to solve but we also
know from computer science that it's
it's a kind of a problem that you can
improve the hardware which is why
everybody use design specialized
hardware for it now because
unlike normal cryptography it's well
that it's not even unlike normal
cryptography in that way but it's
something that you can do a lot faster
if you have Hardware proof-of-work is
basically you have to you you have
people here who are basically laying
down layer of amber around the fly right
and so they have to basically commit
resources to do it it has to be costly
to do that you need scarcity in the
system right so that's the scarcity is
created by the costliness of the
computing power that you throw at it so
basically the more computer power you
want to throw at the Bitcoin network the
more seriously the Bitcoin network takes
your vote and we have to know your
computing power is dedicated to the
Bitcoin network it's not you know off
surfing the internet or doing something
else so you have to commit it to doing
work just for the Bitcoin network and
the proof is through mathematical
functions so you basically have puzzles
to solve the Bitcoin network the
algorithms give the computers puzzles to
solve if the computer solve the puzzle
they can prove that yes I put economic
value time heat power computation into
solving this problem so now I get a vote
on what the ledger looks like and I get
a chance to be paid in coin so that's
what the miner to do the miners do the
work to secure the network using
computers they provide that proof to the
network the network pays them in new
coins that it's my this minting got it
anyway so no Satoshi had an innovation
where he uses this proof of work as part
of the security for people who don't
know who is Satoshi to that name well
it's some unknown character out there
that has disappeared yeah our group yeah
whoever whoever it create a Bitcoin you
know obviously built on Nick's work
built on health in his work way there
were a couple of great computer
scientists who did this work but whoever
actually built the working
implementation because I think Nick you
had you had the theory of bitgold but
you're not a serious in a programmer to
create a bit cold well I'm a serious
programmer but I have to didn't get
around to programming bit cold so yeah
it was a divine and so whoever created
Bitcoin probably a group because it
looks like a very sophisticated effort
did it pseudonymous lee or anonymously
and the the
name that they use the satoshi nakamoto
BIC gold is it's designed on the theory
to use this proof of work as a like all
unforgeable costliness or to constrain
the supply curves you know it's scarce
and satoshi the big innovation was to
well let me backtrack and describe a
little more bit cold so there's a
protocol design for keep airplanes from
crashing because you don't want your
computer to go crash on an airplane and
cause the airplane to crash right you
want to be your computer to be able to
crash an airplane that the airliner
itself going down so what you need is to
distribute this rounds you have several
chips all around the airplane and then
they talk to each other and then if they
get contradictory information they do
what you might call voting they'll take
the majority and consider it to be to
the correct one and that turns out to be
they mathematically prove that this was
the optimal model given those
assumptions that you know how many chips
there are and so forth and this is
called Byzantine consensus so I took
that and used it for this replication
business to replicate the data around
the ledger round with a Merkel tree for
the transaction history and so forth
what Satoshi did was a really big
innovation besides of course actually
making software people could use which I
never did he is the proof of work in
security subs on the internet you can't
count your chip securely you don't know
I have a chip in the tail and the chip
and the wing and so forth did a sock
puppet problem people one person can
pretend to be 100 and wear one computer
can pretend to be 100 Satoshi based it
on proof-of-work basis security that
voting like if the preponderance of the
hash rate tells me that the transaction
is histories been updated and such in
such a way then that's that's it
and again that's good up to 51% that's
where the 51% attack comes from maybe
one computation one vote is the way to
think about it got it and actually you
know one of the one of the problems that
people have with the Bitcoin network of
design so basically a Bitcoin you have
all these computers around the world
that are joining together to create this
shared blockchain computer they get
votes in proportion to how much CPU
power they're allocating they vote on
what the valid transactions are that
then go into this ledger and get sealed
in the amber of the blockchain and the
whole
system kind of works but a naive person
looking from the outside as you said
like the hippie is coming the
blockchains
one of their first objections is you're
wasting all this computer power you're
wasting all this energy you're wasting
all this network resources because
they're constantly chatting with each
other and Network these computers are
broadcasting packets each other all the
time and they just say it's wasteful but
and I think that was an argument that a
lot of people make and even I kind of
fell for that one where I was like okay
you know eventually someone will come up
with a better solution than proof of
work and go to proof of steak or a few
other kind of ideas I've been thrown
around and then Nick just recently wrote
this brilliant piece on social
scalability and whether you've got a
doctorate recently an honorary doctorate
oh yeah at the university Universidad
Francisco marroquín yeah and Guatemala
what is your doctorate in it's in social
sciences and also an honorary
professorship as well so yeah that's
great it's a very long only social
scientist that could talk at this level
well I mean that's the kind of honorary
doctorate they give yeah but yeah it's
been a great lots of luminary so yeah
I'm very honored to have that yet they
cited your social scalability article
and so the social scalability argument I
thought it's a really powerful one I
don't know if you want to try and
summarize back for the listeners I'm
sure so the idea basic idea is that if
you look at a graph of human
capabilities it's basically flat for the
same IQs we had you know if there's a
small thing called the Flynn effect but
under net you know a hundred thousand
years ago our brains were the roughly
the same size they are today and
computers on the other hand have been
you know doubling every few years their
capabilities in various ways their
memory their CPU power network bandwidth
and so forth and so and you can think of
this in the future and get into all
sorts of speculation about the future
but what I like to think of it as we
have this whole surplus we've built up
of resources and yet we're still doing
things institutionally with armies of
bureaucrats and stuff very similar to
what we were doing you know when
computers were you know a thousandth of
the power they are now or a millionth of
the power they are now or they're doing
in the Mongol Empire yeah so in any case
so can we do some substitutions can we
sub
to take advantage of this great surplus
so computer scientists are normally and
engineers are normally trained to think
optimize the Machine make the machine
itself really efficient well what I'm
saying is that you can think the other
way are there ways to make the machine a
lot less efficient and give you some
greater capability so that such as for
example the ability of somebody in
albania to pay some games in bob way
without going through a trusted
intermediary or human bureaucracy ways
to do that you know even if they cost a
lot more and look really bad - an
engineer likes to think about efficiency
so and bitcoin is a great example of
that it's a proof-of-work as part of its
security and in my mind to create that
that scarcity is stepping back for a
second
what separates humans from other animals
is that we are social across genetic
boundaries so you know even the end
results you can have 150 Neanderthals on
a battlefield because they're all
genetically related but you can have
5,000 Homo sapiens in the battlefield
because they believe in the abstract
idea of Christianity and they can
communicate that story to each other
right and so Bitcoin enables the form of
social scalability where it allows now
humans who don't know each other who
don't trust each other who may never see
each other again and don't even reveal
their identities or locations to each
other
- still transact securely not just with
money but also in contracts any complex
logic they can dream up at they can code
up they can do it through this very slow
and very inefficient computer but it
removes all these layers of humans
bureaucrats and toll takers from
operation what right so you're able to
exceed the Dunbar number right exactly
yeah at 150 people Dunbar numbers so
you're basically trading computational
scalability for social scalability
Wilson just to maybe put it another way
and I'd love to be corrected this isn't
right but there's another quote of yours
Nick that I really like trusted third
parties or security holes now yeah I
think relates to this very nicely and
there's a bit on blockchain computers
that I think is relevant so why why make
the trade-off why allow all this
inefficiency
and I'm not going to read this entire
thing but it's the blockchain computer
this distributed blockchain computers
much slower more costly than a web
server by one very rough estimate about
ten thousand times slower more costly
but since on the blotching you're
running the portion of an application
that needs to be the most reliable and
secure what you call this the juicy area
called code because the downside risk is
so high you can afford to have tons of
inefficiency particularly with hardware
that is dropping and cost and increasing
in capability year round here right now
we've accumulated this great great
hardware capacity surplus that that
we're only starting to take advantage of
and so you can use that to do like the
proof of work the very the strong
security protocols that take some
computational effort and also the making
the copies we have lots of memory lots
of disk space lots of bandwidth not vast
amounts but enough that you can you can
take a small transaction and replicate
it around the world make thousands of
copies that helps create stuff flying
amber in fact where you can't deny it
later because everybody's got copies of
it in a way like I think you had a
definition of social scale that in your
article or it's not precise but close
enough where you basically said one way
to estimate how socially scalable
technology is is by how many people can
use it right and when it comes to cash
today like like the US dollar it's you
know accepted probably the most widely
accepted currency in the world but we're
still talking hundreds of millions to
maybe a billion people can really use it
in their everyday life whereas Bitcoin
in theory when it said when it's adopted
can be used by anyone to pay anyone as
long as you connect it to the internet
and everyone's connecting to the
internet it scales better I'm going to
ask a question that came up a lot and
it's one that I don't have any any
ability to answer is it possible to for
any government entity to regulate
Bitcoin or cryptocurrencies out of
existence if so where would you put the
likelihood of such a thing happening or
being able to be implemented by me
because these copies are all over the
world they're never going to get rid of
these copies somebody's always going to
have the transaction
Street and can start it up again yeah so
that good sense makes it very difficult
to regulate there are easier parts of it
to regulate such as the exchanging of
fiat currency your local currency to
Bitcoin back and forth those still
happen through centralized exchanges
which both makes them fairly easy to
regulate and also makes them insecure
trusted third parties or security holes
so if you want to get in and out of
Bitcoin you're usually doing it through
these centralized exchanges and that's
where the vast majority of thefts and
hacks of a Bitcoin have occurred these
exchanges essentially end up like banks
their honeypot so regulators their
honeypot speed is there how do you buy
or sell say Bitcoin without going
through today you do that through a
central it through an exchange there's
also sort of local meetups there's like
there's these sites like local bitcoins
and there's a few others there's a big
one coming up in China now where you can
just sort of coordinate a meet-up with
somebody in a dark alley and you
exchange cash for a Bitcoin so people
can't fall back to that and and the
volume on those kinds of distributive
exchanges have gone up a lot if you look
a bit torrent which is the file sharing
technology here accounts for like a
ridiculous amount of Internet traffic
Bram Cohen invented it you know that
thing on given day can account for with
a quarter to half of Internet traffic
and you can bet the governments that
have been trying to shut that down
because right now the government's are
overzealous and nothing in so much to
enforce and copyright law we want to
drive you know you want to drop the full
weight of the federal government on you
you either engage in you know terrorist
activity or evil at copyright oh they're
like roughly equivalent right they'll
drop helicopters in your house in New
Zealand you ask Kim calm for violating
copyright law even if you've never set
foot in the you managed such an
understated lifestyle yeah and I caught
on to him but yeah so I don't I don't
think government can really shut it down
not only that but any government that
really embraces Bitcoin or any of these
cryptocurrency doesn't have to be
Bitcoin they could even kind of start up
a new one if they wanted to
is this going to benefit so much from
really owning the money that's native to
the Internet
you know I call Bitcoin the internet of
money because it's it's really native to
how code works so if you really want to
future-proof yourself it's like it's
like imagine if the u.s. cracked down on
it and said no more cryptocurrency that
would be saying like saying no more HTTP
right and the country that did adopt
HTTP and by the way this is the HTTP of
money would end up so much better off
that used to be shooting yourself in the
head so I think smart people smart money
in the u.s. already recognizes that and
so it's seeping up into the government
where they're figuring out like yeah we
could we could be draconian about this
we'll just drive it out of the country
it's already happening to some extent a
lot of the icao that are happening we're
happening at a switch to energy Balter
those teams are leaving the US actually
because especially places like New York
have been very heavy-handed in their
regulations so you're just driving out
innovation what is the incentive for say
New York to be supportive or at least
maybe cast a blind eye to development of
this type of technology just like the
internet took out Hollywood with Netflix
and you know Spotify and it took out
newspapers with publishing and Twitter
and Facebook and it's taken out you know
all kinds of industries the internet is
going to fundamentally change and
possibly take out the finance industry
as we know it and the new finance
industry is going to settle wherever the
home of innovation is for smart
contracts and cryptocurrency this is my
belief obviously not investment advice
but I think this is so convey lease
replacement of a lot of the
infrastructure of Finance and so if New
York chooses to drive that out then New
York will no longer be the center of
finance got it every time I go to New
York I'm actually highly entertained
because I see all these huge towers I
see all these people in suits and I know
that 90% of them will be obsolete within
20 years nice horse and buggy oh I like
that yeah well I would I would not be
thinking about going into Investment
Banking right now because a lot of that
job is going to be automated commercial
banking automated you know the bankers
were the minors of the last generation
they got paid in the currency to secure
the currency so when the Fed wants to
yeah they weren't even the miners or the
traders yeah well the Fed wants to
distribute currency to give it to the
banks and guess what the banks the banks
have sticky fingers and then they
allocated out to the rest of us very
sparingly and the new bankers are the
miners the new Fed is the cryptographers
but really the new owners of the
infrastructure are the holders of the
coin which is everybody or could be
everybody is cryptocurrency or let's say
Bitcoin inversely correlated to any
particular other asset classes for
instance when people are fearful of say
currency devaluation they might run the
gold right it's seen this in places like
Argentina seen in the US see all over if
you see that also with Bitcoin in in a
particular pattern yeah they definitely
are store of value because Bitcoin
there's only gonna be 21 million ever
the whole way the protocol is designed
you can't create a single one more and a
bunch of been lost so because they're
hard to secure hold on they get lost
well you could lose your key so you call
I so understand all of it so I really
can't forget your gut Tim or you kind of
defend it you're trying to hide it from
hackers so you come up with some really
elaborate scheme and how to secure it
and then you lose it or people have lost
the computer that it was on you know so
where's who have you heard any third
catastrophic stories of people with like
you know digging through garbage dumps
with bulldozers trying to find that old
computer which they threw out which had
you know 10,000 Bitcoin on it and you
need to get hardware well if it makes
encrypted backups so that you're neither
stolen from nor we lose your king yeah
so I mean there's a finite number of
Bitcoin so bitcoin is electronic gold
there is a generation of kids who will
grow up that as long as they've been
alive like my son when he's older as
long as he's been alive there will have
been gold and they will have been
Bitcoin you think the likelihood of
Bitcoin in any way falling out of reach
for people like your son is close to
zero I don't think Bitcoin itself may
suffer because it has governance issues
and another currency like we should talk
about etherium and some of the others
that are coming up might take its place
but the idea that blockchain computers
are going to go away is ridiculous
that's like saying the Internet's going
to go away
just two fundamental of a technology
barring a total mathematical
breakthrough that obsoletes all
encryption which would also be the end
of the commercial Internet as we know it
I think that some kind of blockchain
computer will dominate currency store of
value contract law and any kind of
financial instrument prediction markets
all kinds of things in the future so to
Mike to my kids they will choose
electronic gold they will choose big
gold and its successors over real gold
Nick what is this is another one of
these words that comes up at dinner
parties and various conversations and I
kind of not long so embarrassed to ask
questions
fearing I'm the only one at the party
kind of like everybody goes to summer
camp and they all miss their mom but no
one wants to talk about it and admit
cerium what is a theorem so so we talked
about the blockchain computer so Bitcoin
honor if your audience and hearken back
to the beginning of Apple Apple Computer
where Steve Wozniak was working at
Hewlett Packard on a scientific
calculator and it had a certain limited
scripting language that you know
specialized for that it wasn't a
full-fledged general-purpose language
that you could do lots with but what he
did was he got excited that his
circuitry
you know chips were getting cheap enough
that you could do the full-fledged what
they call Turing machine after Alan
Turing because he's one of the inventors
of it I'm a full-fledged general-purpose
machine that can do any mathematically
feasible computation and so bitcoin is
like a restricted computer does certain
things specialize like the multi-sig I
talked about and certain other other
things that can do but aetherium is a
much more general-purpose computer and
it also stores long term state better
which is that's a technical thing but
it's an important difference so
basically a serum has great potential
for this reason it has potential to do
smart contracts much better than Bitcoin
does the drawback going to this is it
also increases the attack surface it's
what the serums doing is riskier the
attack surface attack surface so you can
think of of your house is having a TAC
surface there's windows and doors and
places
people can get in right well the
etherium thing has more surfaces that
people could potentially get in because
people are doing more things God adjust
more vulnerabilities that correlate to
more functionality right so much more
flexible computer so you can talk to it
in many many more ways you can inject
bad code in you can hack it many many
move another thing that makes it risky
is that it's newer it's it's not much
more advanced than where in terms of its
maturity and getting out all the bugs
and stuff as Bitcoin was when people are
paying 10,000 Bitcoin for a pizza and
and yet what's the theory market cap now
I think it just crossed like eight or
nine billion today yeah so the market
caps are fuzzy because if you calculated
properly based on the future issues of
the coin it might actually be
approaching bitcoins market cap it might
be in the twenty billion range once you
take inflation into account anyway even
with just the ten millions out there or
eight billion out there now that's
that's a lot more money than Bitcoin had
at the same stage of maturity so I
definitely say it's at a riskier state
but it's also much greater potential
yeah I mean this is so now we're I think
we've done a lot of background in
and I think what people really want to
hear from Nick about is a little bit
more the advanced stuff right because
you did they call you the smart
contracts so they kind of want to know
where you think the future is headed and
I know the future is impossible to
predict them against not investment
advice but very generically what
platforms are you most excited about
where would you spend your time if you
were like a young fresh person walking
into this space so I am excited about a
cerium and a theorem classic and there's
a what's called a sidechain for Bitcoin
called rootstock that they hope to
combine together the best of a cerium
with with Bitcoin on the chain so you
can trade the Bitcoin currency but do
the turing-complete full-fledged smart
contracts the potential there is that
and there very well could be other
turing I mean there's a few other
turing-complete ones out there and yet
probably quite a bit more in the works
as well
anyway the potential for this stuff is
that doing cross-border things and other
things we're crossing a trust boundary
and you don't necessarily have access to
good legal legal affordable legal
counsel for financial contracts
especially as low hanging fruit because
those are usually very well defined and
bureaucrats like to make complications
and add all sorts of epicycles to them
but really an option and a future and
stuff they're they're logically and
temporally pretty simple things to do
and once you get more of the underlying
assets you can do options and futures
you know as for example exchanging
Bitcoin for a cerium and we're getting
all these other tokens that are going to
be on these block chains you'll be able
to include in that now if you go off
blockchain
you got to kind of take a different tack
the words if you're connecting your
smart contract to the real world you
need that you need to know what happened
in the real world decide whether or not
to execute you're smart right so if
you're doing an Apple stock for example
because that's that's a traditionally
defined thing that depends on
traditional systems to make it work
incentivize Apple to pay the dividends
and and do what they do in any case if
you want to do that then all of a sudden
you're back in the traditional financial
world and the traditional financial
people know that right now there's like
a a cultural disconnect that Bitcoin
people have a really cool technology and
but they hate the people in the
financial community don't want to talk
to them though and learn from them and
same to some extent with these Syrian
people as well and on the other hand the
financial community people hate and
don't understand blockchains and
cryptocurrency fact there was this whole
bunch of very dubious startups that
raised a bunch of money to do things
they call block chains at work they
didn't have blocks I didn't have chains
they weren't didn't have security I was
talking about but the marketing people
one call them block chains they could
pretend to be like Bitcoin and you know
the price going laps just commuting
dollars by later yeah of these like the
most of the private blockchain come yeah
I'm not going to name them yeah yeah so
the financial people don't understand it
and they've gotten burned by some of
these companies so they hate they they
hate it but what really I think for the
entrepreneurial opportunity and some of
your listeners want or looking for none
for an opportunity is to marry these two
so take the best of traditional finance
take the best of the block chains
aetherium if you're doing sophisticated
smart contracts and willing to take some
risks and Bitcoin if your main thing is
cross-border payments take these and and
marry them together figure out ways to
securely reflect assets on the
blockchain using both traditional
financial controls and bureaucracy and
taking advantage technology I think
that's the that's the opportunity people
haven't done yet because of this
cultural disconnect what would you say
are some of the most important valuable
components of the traditional finance
world like where would you start the
traditional paper world is really good
it had a thing called separation of
duties where as we talked about multiple
people signing off on things and looking
things you have to go through multiple
stages like if you get an order the
salesperson has to give the order to the
accounting department and they have to
give the order to the manufacturing
people and everybody records it so it's
like a little mini mini paper blockchain
that that people used to have with
computers that's kind of gotten messed
up and hackers can you know what they're
doing can take advantage that these
systems don't work as well now but if
you to a great extent you can make them
work and people do make them work you
know with stock clearing and settlement
and issuance and so forth so anyway yeah
there there are experts in the financial
community don't do that if you can if
you can make them love instead of hate
block chains then you'll have a great
great skill set combination if you can
get the block chain people knows guys
together yeah you're interesting one
because you combine law and computer
science to do unusual things and you're
basically saying is you can combine
traditional finance and now computer
science you do unusual things and right
somewhere that intersection set you can
take a process that's entirely paper and
move the part of it that belongs in the
blockchain on the blockchain well
plugging in the paper part or it used to
be paper and somebody just naively
ported it in some naive and secure
fashion the computers and now you can
use block chains to make it secure more
secure and trust minimizer yeah on the
side of educating oneself so let's say
there are people and I'm sure there are
listening or part of the traditional
finance world so that sounds like a
great idea
I want to learn how to love Bitcoin in
crypto currency I want to learn about
this
how would you suggest they choose
reliable sources of information because
as we've noted before it's a bit of the
wild wild west in some respects you
don't have not everyone is making
disclosures about what they're their own
portfolio might look like so there are
there are a lot of barbers telling you
shouldn't you get a haircut
and how would you suggest people think
about that I mean if you're technical
and want to dive into the engineering
the technology of it
the Bitcoin white paper is still by far
the best place to start and Vitalik
pewter and cerium white paper also what
was that naming
Vitalik petering okay he's a guy who
created it was any developer honestly
Ryoga
he's actually interesting guy young
prodigy probably like 20 or 21 now
started when he was 18 absolutely
brilliant
there is a guy named aviv zohar was
written some great papers one of them is
on ghost which is what etherium is based
on and he's got a follow up to that his
name escapes me and he's also written a
cost and a great paper and attacks
against bitcoin from the underlying
network so he's one of the experts on
the security of bitcoin which is a skill
and knowledge set and scarce supplies
yeah one of the one of the problems and
opportunities here is that you know
going back to that earlier thing it's
about money being the bubble that never
pops bitcoin is kind of a Ponzi scheme
that starts with smart people so the
smartest people understand it first then
they sell it to like the people who need
the cryptography explain to them like me
and then we sell it to the people who
need to the next level down and the
whole thing could pop and end badly so
I'm not saying go put all your money in
Bitcoin but I think to understand
blockchain computer user you sort of
have to get into the math and the code
and the hard stuff but if you wait to
figure it out by the time everyone can
figure it out with the same tools it
will kind of be too late from an
investment or earning perspective it'll
be too late from an investment
perspective or not for me from the
utilization standpoint no of course
you'll be able to use money just as we
use dollars but you're not going to be
investing in something that is going to
hockey stick
yeah the challenge for the industry is
like today Bitcoin has all these
advantages or gold you know it's it's
more easily transmissible it's more
sub-divisional it's more easily stored
it can be communicate by computers but
to the average person that means nothing
all they need to what they need to
experience is they need to receive some
Bitcoin in a transaction and then send
some Bitcoin transaction had the
experience be so much better than every
other experience they've had with money
or a gold and the tools just aren't
there yet like right now securing your
Bitcoin for yourself is still difficult
the hardware wallets are getting better
but it's still kind of a nightmare so I
think the industry still has a decade of
work to do to make cryptocurrencies live
up to their potential and the idea space
is so larger than all these companies
working on but every year it gets a
little easier to use it has a few more
use cases it gets a little easier to
store and and the smart contracts that
are built on it become a little more
interesting so that is a process and
eventually you'll be able to use Bitcoin
without knowing anything about it just
like you can use your thoughts without
knowing how the Federal Open Reserve
Open Market Committee works and you know
does lending and issues Treasury bills
and all that stuff there's only a few
geeks you need to know that in the world
of finance and you can just use money
like it's money just to clarify one
thing sex and money is the bubble that
never pops you're talking about the
concept of money yeah the concept of
money because visual currency is closer
really sure I mean tomorrow I lived in
Argentina between like 2000 mm yeah
tomorrow we all believe that the US
dollar is just a green piece of paper
and I can't eat it I can't do anything
with it or if like aliens came and took
over the world and you know we offered
them little green pieces of paper this
is using the start of bonfire or
something all right so if the money is
just a concept and you have to agree on
what that scarce element is and today
that scarcity is enforced by governments
with guns and central banks and it
breaks down national borders and the
people who secure that money for you
take a huge tax roughly 1/3 of the
economy in exchange for it and
eventually it will be a distributed
network of computers acting in
self-interest who are going to secure
that the scarcity of that money and
hopefully their tax is going to be a lot
lower what else would you you're
obviously much more on the pulse of this
but what other topics
it could be beyond my paygrade it
probably is but should we explore with
with Nick yeah I think I think you know
just talking about blockchains in
general so we started with Bitcoin the
blockchain which is around transferring
money
there's aetherium blockchain and others
like it which are about computation and
running like very slow but very trust
minimized reliable contracts what other
uses can you see for block chains coming
up that you think may be a little
far-fetched maybe 10 years Apple what's
you know what's the possibility space
well I mean one of the possibilities is
that I'm really excited about the
cross-border thing to have say
grandmother's in India and teenagers in
somebody's basement in Indiana doing
what people normally thought were
sophisticated financial contracts such
as options futures etc you know through
this online vending machine in the cloud
that's blockchain so that that's an
exciting and probably many people
disturbing possibility I think is going
to be coming up in the next 10 to 20
years yeah I mean so you could have like
people loading each other money or
creating credit instruments or engaging
in prediction markets and things like
that yeah blue team of prediction
markets well I'll talk about one that
the insurance people are working on
which is related which is parametric
contracts so normally an insurance will
pay out you know if you get damages from
a flood and have to come estimate your
damages which is basically a a wet human
exercise and you know eyeballing how
moldy your wall is and how much you got
flooded and stuff but drier way to do
this is called parametric contracts
where like if you're a hotel in an area
got hit by hurricane you can measure how
much business you lost on your
accounting books and you can
parameterize that and basically have
your smart contract pay off if your
books go below a certain time or pay you
more as the fog your books go down so
that ensures kind of what you really
want to ensure they tell really want to
insure which is their business and it's
also dryer it can be done by software
verifying you know what the books are so
you can make a smart contract out of
that and there are other parameterised
contracts as well based on others
things that computers can sense and
measure in prediction markets are you
know people can actually make
predictions and get paid if their
predictions are correct or lose money if
their predictions are wrong and then
these prediction markets can also serve
as arbitrators of truth and pricing into
these smart contracts so for example you
know in next case the next example the
you tie in directly to the hotel's books
the hotels lost revenue and so you know
whether or not to pay the hotel but if
there's a flood I want to say was the
hotel in the affected area was the hotel
itself affected you need now it's called
an Oracle you need someone who's
basically going to go in there and say
like yes this happened no they didn't
and prediction markets through very
sophisticated engineering which i think
is beyond the scope of this conversation
basically try and pay that person for
telling the truth in a reliable way
and so you can use that to cross the
divide between the wet space and dry
space or from the real world into
computers to have them do these things
you see usually the insurance markets
being completely overhauled by blotchy
and computers and insurance the huge
industry gigantic a lot of it just
belongs in the blockchain I don't think
you're going to have like you know
bankers in Bermuda doing this twenty
years from now you do nothing I don't
think - yeah
because of the technical barriers to
understanding or challenges let's say
lead I think the space to be susceptible
to say charlatans for very smart who can
fool people who don't understand
technical aspects a lot of scams in the
space how do you what are the
characteristics of charlatans or scams
in the space you know it used to be
easier to spot but louder they talk to
the scanner they were now I think it's
the scammers have gotten really
sophisticated
some of these scammers are like version
5 of their scam so they'll be selling
some coin and they'll be talking about
how it like enables some functionality
when reality the code doesn't or they
have some backdoor where they're selling
your scarce coin but they can print a
lot of them so in that sense you know
there's there's a couple of coins that
are sort of in the top set that are
regarded as top-flight that'll legit but
you what is a Bitcoin in theory I'm a
kind of the best known ones then there's
sort of a second-tier contender list of
you know Z cash Manero
like coin etc you know there's some new
ones coming up like Tasers then they
seem more legit but you you have to know
your stuff and do your homework it's not
something what I would recommend you
just run out and buy and then there's a
long tail of coins where there's a
diamond in the rough here or there but
there's a lot of junk - so what's
attracting people just how much money
you can make in this space you know
bitcoin has basically doubled in value
every year since its founding it's oh
it's good and you know you do that for
eight ten years and you end up with a
very very steep curve something like
aetherium if you bought it when it was
sold in original presale today and just
a few years later you'd be sitting on
hundreds and hundreds of times your
money and you'd be fully liquid but this
is not unrecognized the space has
increased in value so much the market
cap of all the cryptocurrencies is more
than double just in the last quarter so
there's a lot of hot money flowing in
will flow back out possibly are we in a
bubbly environment probably will this
bubble pop nobody knows would pop across
the board or will it pops electively or
will it pop later than a different pop
so it won't matter it'll be a flight of
money from one asset class exactly or
will the value switch from Bitcoin to
etherium will Bitcoin forking the two
competing coins because people
are arguing over whether the block size
should be increased or not there's so
much craziness just just to pause on
that word because this when I was
attempting to educate myself and doing a
pretty mediocre job of it this word fork
came up over and over again it's in my
mind I'm envisioning something reading a
lot about dia
so the making of the modern world in
jenga's con and all this stuff Imogen
and I thanks Pam Carlin for the hardcore
history I you would always you would
have these internal factions that would
then split off as two or more cigar
groups in this context what is for
coming and how should how should I think
about it in a coherent way this is this
is open source code so I can take
Bitcoin I can create a copy tomorrow and
it can change it so that all the
benefits go to the ball and right and
that's a fork of Bitcoin that I'll call
navall coin now in reality people
hopefully do more interesting Forks so
there's a fork of Bitcoin called
litecoin which use a different mining
algorithm a different way to
authenticate the miners there's another
for call Z cash which uses different
privacy routines to basically allow for
private transactions so other people
can't look in the ledger know who who
spoke didn't got it so not every node
has full ledger
correct well every note is a full ledger
but it's cryptographically hidden so you
can't tell who sent who how much money
no no in the fork you just talked about
Z cash and litecoin they started over
from scratch they started their own
transaction history and scratch there's
another more troublesome kind of fork
where you don't start from scratch
you're just upgrading the current
software with the same transact with the
ongoing transaction history and you're
trying to convince people to follow and
come a very political political process
fighting over the key Angela - and and
since you know Bitcoin has you know the
the 20 plus billion dollar value you
know people would much rather you know
make put their favorite idea into
Bitcoin then go off and start their own
cryptocurrency from scratch it's like
Bitcoin only better yeah and yeah and so
there's tremendous political fights over
over upgrades in the space just those
are the bad blood comes to a huge debate
right now and the big
world where they're fighting over and
and the basic question is do you
increase the size of the ledger
it's the block size debate do you
increase the size of the blocks to hold
more transactions so then you can bring
down the cost of each transaction so
that I can go and buy coffee and Bitcoin
or do you leave Bitcoin alone and treat
it more as like a Swiss bank where you
only move around money rarely in large
quantities and the smaller transactions
are done on another layer on top where
you create another software layer on top
they call it like lightning Network as
an example of that layer they could
which can be used for very small very
fast transactions and micro payments or
not even micro but even like paying five
dollars for you know at Starbucks
because Bitcoin literally every time you
do a transaction there are thousands of
tens of thousands of computers all over
the world that are recording that
replicating that and storing that for
all the time right that's a lot of work
yeah where you could probably run all of
visas computational power on a single
iPad today but this much more
centralized systems are much more
efficient but they're much less secure
that's kind of the trade-off yeah and so
this yeah I mean the first choice isn't
for the blockchain itself really a
viable choice in terms of scaling is it
scales from you know ten times the value
of transactions value per second of
transactions is today because the
capacity is limited there's these full
nodes that are running that require a
certain band what they have to talk to a
lot of people make a lot of copies to
replicate to stuffer em and so there's a
second layer and of all was talking
about that really the people buying the
coffee are going to have to transition
to and this has caused a lot of friction
because people are going to have to
transition for the small everyday
purchases from Bitcoin the blockchain
itself to this second layer and there's
competing designs for the second layer
and so forth and so there's there's
plenty of things to call as political
friction going back to the money
definition the debate is is Bitcoin
really a store of value or is it a
medium of exchange and so Nick I know
you don't want to get into the middle of
the politics of it but just from pure
computer science perspective like if you
were designing you know if you're
redesigning a bit gold today and you
want to incorporate
these learnings where would you fall in
on would you go for larger blocks would
you go for a second layer oh no I
definitely offer a second layer I mean I
designed Bick aren't gold with two
layers because and can you explain just
I must have lost something just what
that second layer is one more time the
first layer is the blockchain itself the
Bitcoin we call the capital B blockchain
doing the secure transactions and the
ones you can do from Albanian ISM Bob
way without a trusted third party going
through the blockchain and the second
layer and the ability to grow the
transactions per second on that is very
limited you can grow the value per
transaction quite substantially but the
ability to grow transaction per second
is limited because those have a certain
size and you have to make copies of them
around it and so forth I see so the
second layer would be for the coffee the
pizza yeah and so as this grows as more
and more people start using this they're
competing for that that limited block
space and the fees are going up and so
if you want to have a cup of coffee
without having to pay as much fees you
paid for the coffee
you know in two or three or four years
from now you're going to have to use one
of these sidechain what I call
peripheral financial network that it's
collateralized on the blockchain it's
almost trust as trust minimized as the
blockchain itself but it's for lower
value transactions that only
periodically settle on the blockchain we
talked a little bit about the I suppose
third-party tools of application layer
exchanges and so on the user experience
being suboptimal currently but what if
you could wave a magic wand and make
certain things happen make certain
people invest in say Bitcoin what is
what would be required to help Bitcoin
across the chasm to become much more
mainstream maybe it's just inevitable
and it's a matter of time that could be
it but if you wanted to accelerate the
process and it was like okay we can make
wave a magic wand and you can choose any
group of people to invest save ten
billion dollars into Bitcoin or whatever
the number is and then
X Y & Z that would help mass adoption
and the crossing of the chasm what what
are the things that come to mind well I
mean currencies of tradition associated
with government's because especially in
the modern time they're the largest
creditor and the largest debtor and so
they're they have the plurality of the
say and what is the you know the the
money other people are going to use so
right now bitcoin is being used for a
snitch purposes where the Fiat system
which is a very what they call
permission system so blacklist people
I've met people at Bitcoin conferences
they've got plenty of money and stuff
but they've been blacklisted they can't
open bank accounts and so forth so
there's actually the heart the hardest
thing no no not necessarily it could be
just they're you know they're suspected
of something or the money laundering
laws are such that you know if somebody
does something that look suspicious you
have to block it yeah and so there's a
lot of use of that kind of very
erroneous error-prone permissioning that
goes on with the bank system that
doesn't go on with Bitcoin yeah or
PayPal I was just thinking friend from
New Zealand for a host of so
coincidental factors just had a huge
huge nightmare and it took months to
result yeah the way I participate in
cryptocurrency investing these days
because I don't have to worry about how
do you procure it how do you secure it
or even what to buy is I invest in hedge
fund in the space and I've actually
joined one loosely the venture partner
and the biggest problem they have is
getting bank accounts because the
regulator's dig in too much if you're
sending money in and out of Bitcoin or
theorem exchanges it's just something
they haven't seen and they don't to deal
with it because banks don't they don't
have a sister to charge you more for new
weird stuff so just plugging into the
existing banking infrastructure is hard
and that's probably where if they're if
countries do crackdowns it'll probably
happen in that area so how do you fix it
or if if you had close to infinite
resources and could just make certain
things happen - yeah facilitate good
things or prevent bad things yeah I mean
first I would
them into the existing banking system in
a much better way the existing banks you
know should accept that if there's a
legitimate player here they're only
working with currencies that aren't
scams maybe they have some you know
bonded collateral or something like that
and they're legit actors they should be
part of the banking system because the
future of the banking there must be
banks because bank there are all today
thanks I do exist they do exist it's
just they're much harder to find that
you would think so then they're more in
Romania down the street from 20 Western
unions and they're there warming up to
if the forward-looking ones are warming
up to it but we're talking about going
from like one bank in the country to
like 10 banks in the country you know or
five so it's still not a large set these
are small banks generally like Singapore
should get on that everybody this case
is why some of these companies are going
to Singapore actually yeah and actually
the the the warning trend that I'm
seeing is a lot of the more interesting
development teams and companies are all
locating overseas fleeing overseas one
thing is that Bitcoin and the other
cryptocurrencies they operate under such
different principles of the banking
system that people in the banking system
they look at you know these debates
about block size and the people calling
each other names in the basics of a low
level of trust that exists because it
can exist in the Bitcoin community and
they're horrified because you couldn't
run a bank that way you have to you have
to be much more polite and careful and
because they're what were right right
because it's a wet social system rather
than based primarily on dry computer
science yeah you have a system here that
allows anonymous trolls to engage in
complex financial transactions so they
can I think in screaming each other in
college their names while still doing
business yes exactly that's the power of
the system but it looks it looks
horrific they see us from the outside
and that's why you have this cultural
gap people the banking system look at
this and go this is this is terrible
this can't possibly work but to actually
answer your question it's like what
infrastructure needs to exist to make
this space happen security is a big
issue I think your average person today
if they buy coin they don't know how to
deal with what's called custody which is
just how do you hold on to it in a way
that if you if you don't go overboard in
security you get hacked and if you go
overboard and security gonna forget your
password or lose the private energy
holder thing yeah your
to a garbage man there you know or your
your kids playing with the computer and
website your your wallet file and
there's no way to get it back yeah so I
think there's secured the custody has to
be solved and as Nick mentioned there
are Hardware wallets that are out there
they're starting to get pretty good
they're getting good enough now that you
know the sophisticated people can use
them but eventually they'll have to get
so good that the average person can just
use them without having to think too
much yeah one of the interesting things
here is that Nick's blog is called
unenumerated and I'm going to let him
explain what that means well yeah so the
tagline is an endless variety of topics
it might going to come to an end someday
but I don't limit myself basically what
it means on the topic if I if I think of
something it'll probably be relevant
somehow but it doesn't necessarily have
to be so I don't want to like peg myself
as a certain into a certain subject
matter basically is what I mean yeah and
so everything's a larger point where
Nick doesn't pigeonhole himself and his
interests or his identity and so that
allows it to be more free and explore a
wider range of intellectual topics and
so that's why I really enjoyed reading
the blog and so that gives me sort of
the next set of questions which are all
around just random things in your blog
that I that I've read or things that
I've heard you talk about which may not
necessarily relate to Bitcoin or
blockchains
now you are the first to really
convincingly argue and it's goes way
back about why micro transactions in the
internet were much less likely than
people thought because when I was
growing up on the Internet and then late
90s everyone thought micro transactions
were just around the corner what would
be an example of a micro transaction
it's like every time I hit a web page
with a with an article I pay 10 cents to
read that web page or every time I
listen to a song I pay a penny goes into
that song well it goes to a distinction
I made earlier the computational costs
versus our mental cost and the
computational cost have gotten a lot
cheaper and our brain still the same
size so when you're doing a transaction
you're doing a thought in your brain
about is it worth it and that thought
itself is costly and this is costly now
if it's
ever been modulo you know you get a few
extra market prices and some more
information but the our brain is still
the same size so just because computer
scientists were thinking well because
we've reduced the cost so much now we
can do these really tiny tiny things
because we can do things much time
you're in a pending but the trouble is
about our brains can't handle it
computer is good but our brains can't so
that's what the idea of mental
transaction costs the mental burden
right and so there's a quote that I
really enjoyed and I'm going to try to
not take us too off track but there is
no track that's the good news actor this
is Alfred North Whitehead so quote it is
a profoundly erroneous truism repeated
by all copy books and by eminent people
when they're making speeches that we
should cultivate the habit of thinking
about what we are doing the precise
opposite is the case
civilization advances by extending the
number of important operations which we
can perform without thinking about them
end quote is this applied elsewhere in
your life outside of watch hands
thinking about code and so on I mean do
you other ways that you minimize
cognitive burden and other ways in your
life minimize cognitive burden more
other way making these small decisions
sort of cognitive microtransactions yeah
I would have to think about that four
other things I know what I was thinking
there also he was being quoted by
Frederick Hayek who is talking about how
knowledge is distributed and markets and
some markets have traditionally been a
tool where we can communicate what we
want and how much we have for it and
stuff and that really economized we're
only accumulated you know or only using
a few numbers instead of you know going
on and on about what we want how much we
need and how much we did more deserve it
more than the other guy and so forth so
that right there is a tool of social
scalability because it reduces what
could be a long and drawn-out argument
over you know and to it to a few numbers
no it does as asking we don't have to
get into it because there may not be a
ready answer but because I was I was
with a friend a very very successful
investor close buddy of mine we were
walking through the airports having a
conversation and he said no I've
realized that I opt
- now I used to optimize everything so
now I am eyes one or two things and for
everything else it's just good enough I
basically D optimize everything else and
it's made me in his mind incredibly more
effective by actively D optimizing which
which I find mission concept yeah I mean
you just can't focus on everything like
Charlie Munger is a famously bad driver
okay he's a probably a menace on the
road and it's a good he probably takes
over now hopefully but what's the point
of being a good driver today right
especially if you have some other scope
in your life where you can add unique
value yeah in fact so reading your blog
that all these other little gems that
I've found that can we go back to word
or a name origin for one second sort of
does unenumerated have anything to do
with the ninth amendment of the united
states constitution it does relate to
that too because unenumerated rights
meaning you know there's new things
going to happen with technology and
other unexpected things in the future
and you need just define rights about
around those and so you don't want to
limit yourself to just that old list of
you know we have a right to a free
printing press but we don't have a right
to speak freely you know on Facebook or
Twitter or so forth and so you you have
to adapt old ideas to the future yeah so
basically just because the right is not
explicitly listed there doesn't mean you
don't have it and like all the
unenumerated rights you have by default
and it's only the ones that are actually
restricted the ones that are restricted
that's something that I think our
government and Constitution scholars of
the day just completely forget as shown
by the whole surveillance debate and it
shouldn't even be a debate there's no we
the right to privacy is very clear and
even if it's not explicitly spelled out
our phones are private and our computers
are private and our conversations are
private the ways of thinking you know
the process of thought itself is kind of
interesting right after a while you get
introspective enough and you're like how
am i doing by thinking itself and one of
the things that we run into online a lot
is people jump on any little
contradiction right if I say something
on Twitter
and if I said something different a year
ago or maybe out of context and
different conversation people jump on me
and say well that's not what you said
and someone so it's like a big gotcha
right so I think we have this false
consistency that we all try and throw up
when the reality is we're always
changing our minds and you know I forget
who said it was somebody said when the
facts change I changed my mind what do
you do right so I've gotten I've got
okay with this concept of contradicting
myself right Walt Whitman said like I
contradict myself very well then I
contradict myself I am vast I contain
multitudes right so I've gotten use of
that but then I encountered a concept in
your writing Nick that I liked which is
it which is called quantum thought I
don't know if you even remember this do
you do remember imposter so well that
comes from law school so lost law school
they teach a very different way of
thinking in that you need to take you
know both the defendants and the
plaintiffs side of the issue both sides
of the issue and run down the arguments
as if each one of them is true they
contradict each other of course or at
least the conclusions and and some of
the sub arguments contradict each other
and so I compare this to Schrodinger's
cat maybe it's alive maybe instead maybe
the defendants guilty may be had in the
bath maybe they're not and you have to
keep both of these in your mind at once
yeah so I mean this is not how we are
socially taught to think socially we're
taught you have to have a point of view
you have to have an answer you have to
pick a side make your tribe fit in and
then defend it and be consistent but the
reality is really complicated and so if
you're really smart and you're operating
on the edge of any field or trying to
figure out anything new you probably
need to have quantum thought you
probably have to hold both states in
your head and constantly waiting
probabilities and if you're not shifting
back and forth then either you're not
doing something cutting-edge or you're
not being intellectually honest with
yourself mm-hmm so I've questioned for
you about this and also start with just
an anecdote which was I was at a
friend's house recently and it was
gathering if 20 people or so
and there was some structure to the
weekend and people were broken out into
groups to have various discussions
everyone there very intelligent normally
highly rational and politics was the
topic of the day and it just devolved
into acid spitting and craziness almost
immediately with the exception of one
session and the reason that session was
different is that the moderator said
before we get started I want to go
around the room and everyone needs to
pick one piece it could be a tiny piece
of the opposite side the person they
disagree with and just argue for its
validity for even 60 seconds and go
around the room and did that and it took
ten minutes and then everyone was much
more open-minded and patient and
productive in the conversation so my
question for you leading off of that is
how have you trained yourself to
practice quantum thought or how would
you recommend someone develop that
because it's not something that most
folks think about certainly something
circly I didn't dedicate a lot of time
thinking about I was always more
concerned with defending whatever
position I feel like everyone else
should be engaging in it I should stick
to my no I mean it's good it took you
know quite a few loss takes a few law
school tests to get used to it so one
thing you could do is take the first
year of law school and learn how to do
this but imagining that you're the other
person certainly and going through their
arguments and you might even imagine it
as a courtroom and you trade places you
argue for one side and then the other so
you can think of it as a courtroom in
your mind I think might help some people
it seems like people who have either
self selected by gravitating towards
debate or taken debate where they're
forced to take opposite positions and
counter-arguments helpful as well yeah
this is a classic Socrates right he
would always think he would always just
keep digging and arguing the point and
you could never pin him down on his
beliefs because he was always exploring
the thought space and that's also I mean
this
practice disre people are like I don't
want to be over minded but okay they're
not going to explicitly say that but if
you want to be maximally persuasive you
know Charles Darwin actually did this
very very well what I'm about to say in
Origin of Species is instead of straw
Manning and I think Sam Harris has used
this expression the steel Manning so in
other words he would he would try to
anticipate the objection so that people
would have and then he would not take
the sort of weak and flimsy version of
their argument he would build it up and
make it as compelling as possible before
he would counter it in his own writing
that's the intellectually honest way to
do it which is pretty honest way it's
also a very very effective way right
yeah because then you're actually then
you're actually arguing on the real
merits not on what you none of the
anecdote you pick the right at least of
it that you pick to attack to Neil
Strauss isn't a time New York Times
bestselling authors been on the podcast
but he said every time he edits his own
work first he edits for himself it keeps
he wants to keep an interesting phone
for himself second he edits first fans
make sure everything is clear and then
he edits for his haters absolutely you
can steal them and bulletproof things
they expect possible Twitter's taught me
that I mean you have got 160 characters
everything you say 140 most the time
everything you say will be taken out of
context and are used to attack you so
you really just have to boil it down you
have to you have to hone it and I tweet
mainly because it helps me clarify my
own thinking mm-hmm it's quite there
Crusaders actually yeah I think they'd
be accidental limit from text messaging
days turned out to be a huge bonus for
it for Twitter yeah I mean so just kind
of moving moving on a little bit there
these other little phrases your coin
that helped me crystallize my own
thoughts so there's a there's a class of
things that people seem to worry a lot
about these days whether it's an
asteroid hitting the earth or you know
apocalyptic scenarios floods China
Skynet AI you know let's just say even
like near-term climate change
predictions like I think we're all
supposed to be underwater by 2020 or
something right but there's definitely a
class of people who will take a
on the internet and blow it out of
proportion sometimes it can be a warning
sometimes can be good sometimes to be
bad like the general AI thing is another
one of these and you summarize this
whole class of statements under what I
thought was a brilliant little moniker
Pascal scams and what does that come
from so that comes from Pascal's wager
and it can be applied to any any claim
that there's an infinite or very large
reward or punishment or outcome of
positive or negative nature and the
argument goes that even if it's very
improbable because this this reward or
outcome is so large you should pay
attention to it right and Pascal
originally basically said you have to
believe in God because just in case
because it's right wrong your eternity
right God doesn't exist who cares right
God does exist you don't believe exactly
so you should believe yeah that was the
audience the basic flaw in this kind of
thing is there is an infinite number of
infinite outcomes if you expand your
space tight Finity there's there's an
infinite number of things that can
happen so you can't the the odds of any
one of them happening are
infinitesimally right so you don't get a
large expected value when you multiply
infinite by infinitesimally
it's some undefined thing you can't
really reason about but at but people do
anyway but people try anyway so they say
well even you know we so this
precautionary principle kind of stuff
you can only take it so far and the
other problem with improbable things he
is there are air bars on the probability
you don't know if it's you know one in a
billion or one in you know quadrillions
or something so right there that changes
your expected value many orders of
magnitude usually you know people are
trying to get attention and so forth or
you know they have a job that depends on
scaring you and they're trying to
they're trying to make you believe the
probabilities higher yeah it's use
Nassim Taleb language and you should
definitely get him on the podcast some
point by the way that's that I can do
that should happen I've had dinner with
him a few times I think that would be
highly entertaining oh yes I want a
front-row seat
supervened but if you tell every image
you know some Black Swan is like that
happen but any particular Black Swan is
very unlikely to happen and so people
are just trying to scare you with a
particular Black Swan and because it can
end your world even in fit a small
probability has to be taken seriously
and you can waste your entire life
worrying about these things whether it's
suitcase nukes or you know another
financial crisis or the world exploding
or imploding or cooling off or whatever
now just to just to touch back on the
Black Swan though now seem and I first
met if you can imagine the circumstances
the day that Lehman Brothers officially
to be imploded right highly improbable
at least if you're looking back so a few
years prior and he has done very very
well financially by not betting on all
black swans but betting on a few select
black swans and bleeding in small chips
for long periods of time before
occasionally having some type of
windfall like that right so in when
you're considering some of these
improbable events how do you decide
which to hedge by certain behaviors or
not for instance in San Francisco the I
really went deep didn't did training
with the Police Department fire
department for a disaster response
looking at the potential consequences of
saying a high magnitude earthquake and
it's like okay it probably makes sense
for me to spend a hundred bucks on
instacart just get mine in reality I get
a trip on your stairwell and I don't
know that's more likely but the point
I'm making is like you most people have
a fire extinguisher in the kitchen that
they will never use right you wear your
seatbelt you've probably never been in a
high impact collision so there are
certain classes that are low cost very
easy yeah in terms of preventative so
how do you think about how do you
personally think about this right I mean
but a not erect not and no that's not
really a problem that I think happens a
lot of people not an asteroid destroying
that's the planet it's a probability
thing yeah we're we're the probability
spectrum is it if it's one out of 10,000
you know you should probably worry about
it or at least take basic precautions if
it could if it has never happened yet
it could happen and would wipe out all
of humanity or like once a generation
then it's sort of in the sphere we just
can't think about it or you just go
insane oh I second a first law to be
able to go you know here are some more
crashing on a magnitude 10 quake in San
Francisco could happen the odds are low
but it could happen you could keep that
fire stinger sure around you could add
some water you could add some things but
you know you're the building you're in
will just collapse on you anyway so well
yeah I mean there's business oh the
extreme example of this the one that you
know a lot of people in our social
circle or constantly peddling is a
singularity example the very seductive
one you know even Elon Musk who's
otherwise absolutely brilliant seems to
be taken in by it and and you know I
give him credit for for worrying about
it and thinking it through and so on but
it's just another one of these Pascal
scams it's using like okay can I come
back to because I know we're gonna
that's alright we're about to I really
does attack the pinata with this uh
hornet's nest for my exact is FL candy I
don't know depends like as an egg about
it but I before we get there Nick is
there anything that you worry about that
many other people don't worry about
things I worry about that many other
people don't I don't know people worry
about so many things
but I mean people worry about privacy
but that seems to be going the wrong
direction
anyway you talked about the singularity
I heard somebody coined the phrase I
forgot who it was creepy Lera T that
were slowly life is getting creepier and
creepier more strangers are appearing in
on more and more personal parts of our
lives so I worry about that goddess I
did you podcast won't help do you take
do you take preventive any particular
preventive measures that other people
might find helpful I do but a lot of
them are security through obscurity so I
can't a guy understood all right so
singularity we do interval actually
before we get into that like I think the
privacy issue is really interesting one
because physical privacy is being
utterly destroyed and other than people
realize the extent to which is going
away because cameras are essentially
your big quitters and face rec and
everyone can track everything
privacy is possible in one realm where
it was impossible for was a digital
privacy and that's encryption that's a
story of blockchains and Bachchan
computers washing computers can enable
digital privacy to a level that you just
couldn't get otherwise
so one of the sets of things we didn't
talk about if things like Z cash and
Manero and other blockchains that are
all about privacy and if you want touch
on that at all yeah there are a couple
so you can achieve because Bitcoin
doesn't require identity you can achieve
some minimal amount of privacy but once
they track you know go to go to the
again the Bitcoin Fiat Exchange they can
tie the address to an identity that way
and trace it back and there are the
minimal basically if you buy on an
exchange they'll know what account that
it the money was sent to or the coins
were sent to and then every time the
coin moves someone can analyze the
blockchain because they have a copy too
they can say went from account X to
account Y account Y to Kanzi and they
might lose track you somewhere along the
way but I even heard someone say that
law enforcement started to refer to
Bitcoin as prosecution futures sometime
in the future they will be able to
unwind that country like we'll do it be
like analyzing Lance Armstrong's blood
ten years later yeah like oh we do have
that we still have a copy and now the
technology got better right execution a
guy named David Chum invented mixes and
applying a mixing tin blinding and
applying this technique to money I'm
Torres aversion applying it to
communications but applying this to
money so you can do a little bit of
mixing or tumbling in Bitcoin but Manero
you can do it quite a bit better and
then Z cash has an even more advanced
privacy features yeah essentially the
Monaro and I don't know the material
community is very acidic and they fight
the Z cash community so they get the
battle to each other but there are
different approaches like one approach
is I'm doing a transaction and there
five other people do a transaction we
all pull our transactions together and
then so someone who's trying to analyze
the blockchain will just see that five
trans
we're done these are five participants
but you've lost they can't tell what
went to whom and something like z cache
takes it a step further and just the
entire ledger is opaque like it's all
cryptographically protected you can't
tell who exchanged what and there are
these crazy complicated proofs that go
into proving who still has what money
and in theory the cash is much is very
private it's sort of the extreme edge of
privacy but it's computationally
extremely expensive it's brand-new
cryptography which hasn't yet withstood
the test of time what makes a particular
currency appreciate and value I know
this is probably stupid sounding
question but I guess there's because on
one hand you have these nuanced sort of
technological features right so someone
might focus or take as a particular
currency my focus more on privacy and
then another might focus more on XY and
Z then you have supply and demand right
if Kim car if Kim Kardashian gets up
tomorrow morning and decides that she's
read a lot about Bitcoin and wants to
Instagram about it for the next ten days
straight I would imagine that would have
an impact on prices and then you can
look at a framework of you can say first
of all is this doing something novel and
useful like it's as useful it's privacy
useful is computation useful it's
exchanging money useful then you can say
is this the right technology solution
because it's probably 20 other
blockchains competing for it then is it
being adopted
is there a network effect people have in
their wallets as the infrastructure
exists are they using it and then supply
and demand and and that gets gamed a lot
sometimes the developers of these coins
are pumping out more coins in the
background you don't know where they
reserve the right to read the source
code to figure it out so that's why
investing in some of these extreme
so-called all coins or app coins is very
scary but there are other applications
coming up that are really interesting so
there's like a one coming out called
foul coin where I'm a small investors
our disclaimer but there are others is
storage storage a and others like that
also that are basically trying to create
a network of distributed computers that
will do storage for you so instead of
uploading your file to Dropbox or Amazon
you can upload massive files into these
distributed storage networks that will
take your data encrypt it split across
thousands of machines and then they'll
test to make sure your files still
available the network if you ever need
it back and then you'll pay people in
the coin and so people who you don't
know grandmother's in India might be
holding a piece of your file and waiting
to serve it back to you when you need it
as a backup or just for storage or
serving and you'll be paying them fully
anonymously and from far away and the
whole transaction is handled through the
network there's another one called block
stack which is building an
infrastructure for the decentralized
internet including domain names name
serving done in the distributed fashion
today all the name servers are
controlled by ICANN and Verisign and so
on but what if you could split that out
amongst a distributed network of
computers you could pay people and coin
on the network for doing that so these
kinds of applications are coming up and
for each one of these you look like is
it novel is it useful what's the
competition is the code secure other
developer scammers or their backdoors
what's the supply and demand
so it's still completely Wild West which
is both the opportunity and the terror
of it I mean I think the average person
is investing in coins on most of them is
probably gonna lose their shirts over a
long enough period of time because the
scammers are really sophisticated but I
think they're really smart people who
know what they're doing and maybe get a
little bit lucky they're going to make
generational fortunes Nick what are your
thoughts on singularity so well I'll get
back to Pascal I was doing I was going
to try to do something clever with
generations and I'd like you know what I
can do this a lot of the ìiî SEOs are
scams and Pascal scams are these big
scams where like you can't calculate the
probabilities because you're dealing
with affinities and the most recent of
the Pascal scams is making the rounds is
a singularity movement yeah so I mean
the idea of the singularity they've seen
this exponential growth and computer
resources and the fact that computers
are outstripping humans and then they
sort of impute from that that and you
can also see computers take over you
know things that used to be considered a
sign of intelligence to be able to add
and subtract quickly and now computers
can do that billions of times faster
than you
so and and the gap keeps growing and
growing once the computer can do
something the gaps just going to keep
growing and growing
but the idea the singularity tends to be
that you get a general intelligence like
it at some point computers can do
everything humans can do and also you
know very quickly they can go faster and
faster and faster they start designing
improved versions of themselves and it's
a runaway effect in humans soon become
obsolete or pray for terminators and
what I we can't predict and so one of
the one of the conceits is the idea that
I will no longer be able to predict the
future the thing is that's that's
basically true today for a lot of things
you can't you know you know the stock
market's an ongoing running singularity
you can't predict day to day if you
could you could make a fortune so yeah
you've laid out a lot of arguments
against it I'm another one it's just
what is this general intelligence thing
like humans are highly adaptive
specialized machines and every other
animal that's around today for include
in the cockroach it just as evolved as
we are it's just different Fitness
functions and so it has a different
concept of intelligence that needs to
survive and machine intelligence that
we've developed so far two extremely
specialized so there probably is no such
thing as general intelligence instead
what we have is machines that are
brilliant at calculation but terrible at
other things and now they're getting
brilliant face recognition but that
doesn't mean they're going to be really
great at me solving my next debate with
my wife
well did something else you touched on
that I appreciated and as a
non-scientist non-engineering sometimes
pretends to do such physical performance
and whatnot quote there is as Fineman
said so it's richard fineman everybody
should read surely you're joking mr.
Feinman but I digress there is a spine
man said quote plenty of room at the
bottom end quote but it is by no means
infinite given actual demonstrated
physics that means all growth curves
that look exponential or more in the
short run turn over and become s curves
are similar in the long run unless we
discover physics that we do not now know
as information data processing under
physics as we know it are limited by the
number of particles we have access to
and that in turn can only increase in
the long run by it most acute polynomial
and probably much less than that since
space is mostly empty
it seems underlying the singularity is
the assumption that
Financial continues during exponential
indefinitely
right and we've had exponential growth
for computers for most the last century
and so we have this vast resources that
I've already talked about to take
advantage of but the future you're going
to face these physics limits you know
limits on the heat that your circuits
give out they turn into toasters and and
so forth so yeah and it's the limit set
by quantum mechanics and we're we've
reached that and some I don't think
Moore's Law really applies to
transistors necessarily anymore the
original Moore's law about the number of
transistor Bank that's already the
physical limits of how far transistors
can go then there's a question of our
transistors even the right medium like
maybe to exhibit our kind of variation
of specialized intelligence it needs to
be on wetware like it needs to be on
tissue and we have not yet gotten to
growing brain tissue and then
programming it that's a long ways off
and then you have deal with the fact
that our brains evolve in our
intelligence involves in reaction to our
environment and even genetic algorithms
evolved in reaction to fitness functions
so you not only would you have to create
a computer that could run on our tissue
to inhibit to exhibit our kind of
intelligence but then you would also
have to put it in our kind of
environment and it's rate of learning
would be limited by what inputs our
environment can provide and if you're
going to go do all that work then just
have a baby takes nine months and we
already know how to do anything we're
high
well on that point related to
environment this is and you've written
quite a bit on this but I underlined one
portion quote so these evolutionary
techniques and other machine learning
techniques are often interesting and
useful but this is the severely limited
ability of computers to simulate most
real-world phenomena means that no
runway is in store just potentially much
more incremental improvements which we
which will be much greater in similar
bull arenas and much smaller than others
and will slowly improve as the accuracy
and completeness of our simulation slow
improves just to underscore what you
just said you need access to the
environment or the ability to create
right there's also a probabilistic
argument against general intelligence
which is the universe is so vast and so
large that if general it's the same is
the same people who make
general intelligence argument also make
the we're living in the simulation
argument well the kind of both can't be
true because if we're living in a
simulation then that means that at some
point we already invented a general
intelligence like when you get the
technological capability to invent a
simulation is complexity
probabilistically and you believe
general intelligence are possible into
the mechanism described in the
singularity then we probably already hit
that along the way so that means that
whatever that general in AI is already
exists we're just living inside it's sim
so why do we have to worry about it some
of the emerging here then killing us all
so the people who are both holding the
simulation bully hypothesis in their
head and the singularity being on the
corner in their head are sort of at a
deep level contradicting themselves well
particularly if no I guess be so the
simulation I wish we had Sam Harris here
to talk about I don't like mentioned
something I was just talking about free
well he's interesting talked about that
but the the idea that something would
come to be that is a thousand a million
times a billion times more generalizable
intelligent than we are and their
priority would be killing us yeah it's
just like my my my directive in life
being running around killing cockroaches
it's like knowing cockroaches I don't
really care so much about them but seems
odd that that yeah I think that movie
her actually did it pretty well which is
you know when the general AI evolved in
that movie it just left yeah yeah I
didn't care about this world at all
soon of all you've mentioned a bunch of
things you're not worried about I'm
curious to ask you the same question
ethnic which is what are the things that
occupy your mind more than perhaps other
folks or many other people I try to keep
a very low level of mental surface
activity for anything other than
whatever I'm directly dealing with in
the moment and one of the ways I'm
trying to do that is by stripping away
layers of identity so I don't want to
over they identify as Indian or American
or libertarian or Democrat or any of
those kinds of things because one that
sort of keeps me from actually engaging
in thinking as I need to it's all
preconceived beliefs it makes me more
defensive because once you
you can't talk about politics anybody's
because the tax identity at a core level
every tweet I put out I now know that
even if I attack a general class of
activity all the people who are engaged
in that activity will respond so like I
put out a tweet about how you want to
you know value investing and venture
investing or both long term investing
and trading is a good get-rich-quick
scheme which doesn't work
and so of course all the people who got
really angry about that I was quickly to
the buyer and sure enough their traders
like that's what they do they trade all
the time for Wall Street and that's how
they make a living so if you attack
someone's identity you're shut down all
conversation with them that's why
politic political conversations don't
work so conversely if you want to be
rational and open mind that you should
not have an identity and the less of an
identity you can absorb can adopt the
better how do you train yourself to
identify less as Indian as X as one
human consistency bias a powerful thing
so just when someone asked you are you
libertarian to say I'm not anything
if they say like religious you know they
don't say like like Krishnamurti one of
my favorite philosophers when he met the
Pope you know the the Pope said to him
like you know I'm I'm Pope blah blah
blah you know from this lineage and so
on who are you and Krishnamurti said I'm
nobody right but he was being serious
yeah like I don't even know what I am
just being that's here right now in this
environment reacting to the inputs from
the environment according to my
conditioning and I'm trying to be as
unconditioned as possible but that's why
my my Twitter my Twitter avatar is like
a sketch of a human face because it's
trying to remind me to be unconditioned
you don't want to be over conditioned
and you don't want to be overly strong
with your identity you guys mentioned
Twitter earlier so one of the things
that you may have noticed I do this but
I routinely put out things on Twitter
and Facebook that I used to call my
audience of hypersensitive people or
that I know will just kick the hornet's
nest enough to force people to
self-select one way or the other
yeah and I have to be careful not to
then
accidentally create a group where they
all have sort of grew up exactly you
want to screw link you want to prune the
trees of the forest not ruin the trees a
little bit but also what that does is it
gives me more I see I perceive having
more freedom of speech or willingness to
speak my mind because I'm progressively
creating less and less of a reputation
to protect something yes and so that's
right now III do the exact same thing
which is I would say every every couple
of months my tweet stream gets a little
edgier right that's sort of pushed out
the people who can't deal with what I'm
saying
and I've muted them or block them or I
just say one followed me or what have
you and I've been used to block but now
I've had to like it's just cuz there's
always somebody who's straw man whatever
you're saying get outraged and try and
start a fire and assemble a mob around
it to like burn you at the stake and
unfortunately a lot of the best people
on Twitter have left because of that
issue right like tea market probably
being the most famous but you know you
can put out a hundred tweets a day and
you say one thing wrong and one of them
and they're trying to burn you at the
stake it's always the most controversial
ones of mine to get on put on reddit and
spread beyond the footer absolutely yeah
Pete marker for those interested it's
Marc Andreessen I think this is a
general phenomenon where society has not
yet figured out how to deal with social
media I think like in my kids generation
they'll be saying all kinds of crazy
things on Twitter and nobody will care
nobody will lose a job over it nobody
will get worked up over because everyone
was saying everything crazy all the time
but right now and we're transitioning
from a world of our thoughts being
private to our thoughts being public
people are still getting outraged but to
me like the people who get outraged are
sort of the most imaginative least
intelligent members of society and I'm
happy to leave them behind the more
easily outraged you are the less I won't
have to do with you be gone if you think
words can hurt you you're going to live
in a world of misery and pain your
entire life so on that note I'd like to
wrap this guy I so I like your shift for
a second and ask a few questions of unic
that are not directly related to they
might be they might edge into it but not
directly related to cryptocurrency the
first is if
people want to explore your blog and you
have some very extensive writing and
where might you suggest they start is
there a particular piece or a few pieces
that might be a good diving in point for
people yeah I fell for our blockchains
and cryptocurrency and smart contracts
probably the two best ones money
blockchains and social scalability is a
recent blog post of mine and then in a
somewhat older blog post called dawn of
trustworthy computing what are some of
the subjects that you enjoy exploring
outside of the ones that we've already
heard about in terms of the we
understand the fascination with money
currency law what are other interests
that might not be immediately evident to
people if they're reading your blog yeah
we also mentioned the origins of money
origins of money and big interest in
related interest mine and history in
general I read a lot of history any
particular by economic and legal history
mostly so are there any particular
resources or books that you've enjoyed
in that area
um so Alfred crosby's the Columbian
Exchange which is basically what Jared
Diamond ripped off when he wrote his
[Music]
Alfred Crosby wrote the original better
version I know you just ruined Jared
Diamond for me that is a popular
yeah Jared Diamond's hypothesis on what
happened on Easter Island also turns out
nah that's right I've heard not huge
Lapidus
not that yeah but yeah we all make our
mistakes be it one of the questions I
ask guests on the podcast often times is
what books have you gifted the most
other people and I don't know if you
have any that come to mind
so Richard Dawkins The Selfish Gene is
sort of on my essential everybody should
read this list yeah definitely one of
the classics all the Dawkins is getting
outraged on the internet a lot these
days he's good at that's the same kind
of outrage
oh my god I saw uh yeah public speak
public talk of his in Los Angeles not
too long as foods fantastic but I was
just like every given second I'm like I
wonder if this room is going to explode
like not with outrage applause like
literally any other books that kind of
line and I mean Matt relief written
several good books on evolution social
evolution and a couple of genetic
evolution as well these fellows lesson
Matt our ID le why riddling okay Connor
yeah I think three or four of my top
twenty books of all time are all read
these rational optimist genome Red Queen
origins of virtue which is your favorite
or if you had to recommend one if you
had to recommend one rational optimist
and here's an evolution of everything
which I haven't read yet if you were
teaching a this for you neck if you were
teaching a let's call it a high school
freshman class or seminar I'd be on any
topic what would you teach hmm well I
just gave some lectures at my honorary
Doctorate University on related lectures
on the origins of money and blockchains
and cryptocurrency so to me those are
three closely related topics but I like
to and how have a over what period of
time did he teach at class or whatever
like hour-long lecture so I tried to
cram way too much into there what would
you hope people would take from those
lectures if they only remembered two or
three things is that are there any core
critical takeaways you could help them
so money is not arbitrary if you look at
the history or the money you see all
sorts of different things textiles and
Yap stones and that's net and so forth
but indeed it's not arbitrary they're
very consistent things like unforgeable
costliness the demand for scarce supply
and the durability people choosing
durable objects so that that sort of
realizing that by reading that is partly
what helped me figure out yeah you could
do this in cyberspace as well um so what
does in your in your life what does
money buy you I know that's not like a
not
in my life and yeah yeah not as much as
one would have thought because I find
myself consuming time to do things that
I would I would like to substitute money
for but can't okay I have to take the
time to do them anyway so what what
drives you to write as much as you do
well partly that's what I want to do it
in life so you enjoy the process okay I
like the freedom of thought and stuff
and so I'd much rather sit at home
thinking my own stuff and then you know
thinking what my boss wants me to say
okay what are things you'd like to write
about that you haven't had a chance to
explore yet or that you have on deck so
I've written some things about the
Industrial Revolution that I have some
media sites on but I'm so busy with
other things I'll probably never get to
and on what I call the exploration
explosion how European's were able to go
around the globe and and take over the
world's trade routes and so forth you
know after Columbus so and there's all
sorts of those other two my favorites
but there's there's plenty of others as
well never actually I do
can you can you give any teaser snippets
or concepts from the Industrial
Revolution well I don't I don't know if
this made it on the recording but the
hourglass was mentioned earlier is an
underrated invention this humble glass
thing was sand in it so Europe invented
like the mechanical clock and which I
think most people recognize it as an
important invention but they also at the
same time and not coincidentally that it
happened at the same time they invented
the hourglass and the hourglass keeps
you know time between one hour and
another and then the clock which at the
beginning was only in the bell tower
you know chimes the hour for the whole
city and so it's the hourglass that
people would time their you know their
activities with and so forth and
professors would time their lectures and
people would you know agree to meet at
certain times and just that temporal
coordination was happening quite a bit
more in Europe than than anywhere else
and they also turned it into a
navigational technique called dead
reckoning where you would you
would look at you're not slipping
through the water and then you use the
hourglass to measure the time and then
you would also use that hourglass to
record the time record when you made the
measurement and so you keep track just
dead reckoning of how far you're going
that's a technique Columbus used and
Magellan used and so forth so that
hourglass we've used in all that stuff
and underappreciated underappreciated
yeah there's some for guys job it let's
flip it every hour exactly on the hour
if you had a gigantic billboard to put
anything on instead of a message to get
out to millions of people or more what
would you potentially put on that
anything come to mind I can take
billboard
well the phrasing of all quoted me
earlier trusted third parties or
security holes anybody in the blockchain
space I would I would like to get that
in their head that's basically the key
to the whole divine why the whole divine
is like it is and so forth they've all
you have any other questions before I
wrap up with a few no I mean I would
just really encourage people to go read
Nick's blog he is a true polymath he's
written about stuff as he mentioned
ranging from being our glasses and
clocks the Industrial Revolution to
blockchain to law and policy and privacy
and rights and singularity and freedoms
and it earned something every time I go
to his blog I'll probably not finished
about half the pieces on there and
they're always highly inspirational
educational yeah people often ask me
listeners ask me a question related to
the maxim that you hear in Silicon
Valley a lot which is you're the average
of the five people you associate with
most what do I do if I don't have access
to five people I want to be the average
of the answer or one of the answers is
read choose your reading sources very
wisely and I would agree the depth and
breadth of what you cover is really
really astonishing my smartest teachers
mentors peers these days are all on
Twitter and blogs and there is they're
mostly autodidact like they might have a
they're self-taught right fancy word but
they might have degrees and whatever but
but the reality is they're curious
people and the Internet is the myth of
the Library of Alexandria writ large
like you can find anything and
everything you can become an expert at
you can talk to anybody
so I used to feel guilty about spending
so much time on the internet but now I
don't
long as I'm reading interesting things
from the people that I think are really
smart what's the downside
agreed on Twitter where can people say
hello what is your Twitter here my
Twitter handle is at Nick Szabo for okay
and that's ni ck s Z yes a vo the number
four number four yeah very cool well
that I think about covers it for a first
gathering at cousin of all and you can
get a twenty five percent discount on
the volcano if you go to Tim's on vlog
for lunch - now I'm getting that is that
as head sizes are going up prices are
going up but wait that's not all we'll
have hopefully more for you guys - and
this is a real blast thanks so much for
the time Nick thank you this is really
fun and navall always a pleasure thank
you for helping put this together thank
you for having us fantastic and to have
a great listening we will have show
notes links to everything we mentioned
Nick's blog books in many resources we
can think of probably cryptocurrency 101
a handful of articles will recommend in
sequence as well in the show notes you
can find those at tim log forward slash
podcast and that will take you to show
notes for every other episode as well
and until next time as always thank you
for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday is that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and 500 Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric
as I do it could include
favorite articles that I've read and
that I've shared with my close friends
for instance and it's very short it's
just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed this episode
is brought to you by audible which I
have used for many many years I
absolutely love audiobooks and they are
one of my favorite ways to pass the time
when I travel I'm on the road all the
time and audible allows me to consume
many more books than I possibly could
otherwise I have two audio books to
recommend right off the bat the first is
perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neil narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Ralph Hawks Pio tts which
had a huge impact on my life and formed
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial this episode is brought to
you by fresh books man oh man do a lot
of listeners of this podcast readers of
mine love fresh books to the extent that
I end up meeting with the CEO not very
long ago why are they so popular well
they are the number one cloud accounting
software designed exclusively for
self-employed professionals that's many
of you and used by more than 10 million
people you can send invoices track your
time and get paid very very quickly
which suits the needs of a lot of
freelancers are lots of thoughts
kind of Oz and beyond you can take
pictures of receipts you can link your
credit card and debit card so all the
things you buy automatically appear in
your fresh books in the right category
so on and so forth makes taxes easy
makes invoices easy makes your life
easier and also in fact I recommend a
PDF they didn't ask me to read this part
by the way they put the other PDF a
while back called breaking the time
barrier subtitle how to unlock your true
earning potential so you can search for
breaking the time barrier a lot of
people ask me how can I get a 4-hour
workweek with a service business and the
story in that we book its PDF is the
short answer it's really really good so
I think you should also check that out
so breaking the time error check it out
but also why not test out fresh books
claim your 30-day unrestricted free
trial at fresh ebooks.com forward slash
tim and enter tim ferriss two hours in
two S's in me how did you hear about us
section that sounds like we're going to
get very little tracking that's a lot of
work but just go to fresh books comm
forward slash tim and try it out because
it is a very good product and i think
you will find it simplifies your life
enjoy
[Applause]
you